İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar 17 Şubat 2025 Pazartesi günü saat 19.32 64. ders günümüz dersimize başlıyoruz kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Nerede kaldığımızı şöyle bir hatırlayalım arkadaşlar mutex sınıflarını ve mutex sınıflarını sarmalayan benim tabirimde rayi rapper sınıfları olan efendim onların da bir ismini tekrar sayalım mı lockguard unique lock scope lock ve shared lock sınıflarını gördük bunların kullanımını inceledik.
Şimdi senkronizasyonla ilgili diğer mekanizmaları görmeye başlayacağız dedik bir giriş yaptık ama girişi tekrar yapacağız bu arada bana özelden sorulan birkaç tane soru var bunlardan en azından birine cevap vereyim sorulardan biri şu thread oluşturmanın C++'ın standart kütüphanesiyle thread oluşturmanın tek yolu thread sınıfı türünden bir nesne oluşturmak mı?
Yani bunu oluşturmadan bir thread başlatma şansımız yok mu? Hayır böyle bir şey söylemedim daha oraya gelmedim.
Aslına bakarsanız bir thread'i oluşturmanın standart kütüphane yoluyla bir thread'i oluşturmanın 3-4 tane farklı yolu var.
Bir tanesi en alt seviyeli yol zaten baştan da böyle söylemiştim doğrudan stu thread nesnesini kendiniz oluşturuyorsunuz ve ona bir callable gönderiyorsunuz bunu defalarca yaptık.
Bunu doğrudan stu thread sınıfıyla da yapabilirsiniz ama hatırlayın stu thread sınıfı joinable durumdayken stu thread sınıfı türünden bir nesne joinable durumdayken arkadaşlar eğer destructor'ı çağrılırsa bu durumda terminate fonksiyonu çağrılıyordu.
İşte bunu engellemek için de bir C++20 standardıyla dileklenen C thread sınıfı vardı.
Yani C thread sınıfı da thread sınıfının rayi rapper'ı diyebiliriz.
Ama bizim henüz konuşmadığımız bir özellik daha var C++20 standardına eğer vaktimiz kalırsa en son gireceğim.
C thread sınıfı thread sınıfı türünden bir nesneyi sarmalarken aynı zamanda arkadaşlar thread'i dışarıdan durdurma imkanı da veriyor.
Yani adeta şöyle yapmışlar madem böyle bir yeni özellik koyduk bu sadece bir rayi rapper olmakla kalmasın.
Yani amaç burada sadece join fonksiyonunun çağrılmasını sağlamak, exception handling'e karşı bir önlem almak olmasın.
İngilizce ise kooperatif bir şekilde bir işbirliği mekanizmasıyla aynı zamanda thread'in dışarıdan sonlandırılması imkanı da versin.
Yani thread'in çalışmasının sonlandırılmasından bahsediyorum thread çalışırken.
Ama iki yol daha var.
Yollardan biri arkadaşlar bu yüksek seviyeli yol.
İsmi async olan bir fonksiyon var.
Bugün oraya kadar gelme ihtimalimiz pek görünmüyor.
Ama büyük ihtimalle bir sonraki dersimizde, yani çarşamba günkü dersimizde async fonksiyonunu göreceğiz.
Async fonksiyonu aslında multi-thread programlama tarafında, yani thread oluşturma ve thread'leri kullanma tarafında en yüksek seviyeli araçlardan biri.
Bundan daha yüksek seviyeli araç, doğrudan algoritmaları, ondan da bahsetmiştik en son konularımızdan biri olacak.
Stift plus plus 20 standartıyla gelen özellikle arkadaşlar, algoritmaları, özür dilerim 17 ile gelen özellikle algoritmaları ne yapmak?
Paralel olarak çalıştırmak.
Async fonksiyonunu siz çağırdığınız zaman, bugün belki async için değil ama Studfuture ve Studpromise sınıflarını göreceğimiz için ona değinebilirim.
Arkadaşlar, async fonksiyonu kendisi arka planda thread'i oluşturuyor.
Evet, şimdi yüksek seviyeli tam olarak ne anlamda?
İki arkadaşım da bunu sormuş.
Arkadaşlar şu anlamda, sizden, hatta yazayım ben yüksek seviyeyi İngilizce'de ne anlamda kullanıyorum, Türkçe'de ne anlamda kullanıyorum?
Benim yüksek seviye dediğim terim İngilizce'de high level.
Biliyorsunuz, bunun zıttı da low level.
Evet.
İngilizce diyor ki, yüksek seviye kısmını biraz açar mısınız?
En günceli, en ileri ya da en ileri seviyesi gibi mi?
Asla.
Kesinlikle o anlamda değil.
Aslında böyle sorular çok iyi.
Çünkü böyle bir soru sorulmadığı sürece,
ben herkesin yüksek seviye dediğimde aynı şeyi anladığını düşünüyordum.
İyi ki sordunuz.
Arkadaşlar, buradaki yüksek seviye tıpkı programlama dillerinin düşük seviyeli ya da yüksek seviyeli olması gibi.
Yani düşük seviyeli olması, sizin, sizden daha az şeyin gizleniyor olması.
Arka planda olanı size daha yakından yansıtıyor olması demek.
Şimdi örneğin thread sınıfını düşünün.
Arka planda olanı daha iyi yansıtıyor değil mi?
Ben giriyorum, thread sınıfı türünden bir nesne oluşturuyorum.
Bu nesneye bir kolubılı argüman olarak veriyorum ve thread koşmaya başlıyor.
Ne zaman arkadaşlar ben bu thread sınıfı türünden nesneyle işim bitecek?
Ya join fonksiyonunu çağıracağım ya da detach fonksiyonunu çağıracağım.
İşte olabilecek en alçak seviye, yani threadleri kullanmanın bize en fazla olanak sağladığı seviye bu.
Mesela buradan thread'in ID'sini alabiliyorum.
Arkadaşlar, öyle diyeyim mi?
Efendim, thread'in ID'sini alabiliyorum, native handle'ını alabiliyorum.
Ama bakın şimdi bir de yüksek seviyeyi göstereyim.
Henüz yüksek seviyeyi görmediğimiz için orada tabii soru son derece doğal.
Mesela ben şöyle bir çağrı yapsam.
Bir fonksiyonu çağırıyorum.
Bu fonksiyonun ismi stut async arkadaşlar.
Ben bu fonksiyonla ilgili argümanları geçerken, argümanlardan birin olarak da bir kolubulu geçsem.
Yani argümanların şimdi ne olduğu çok da önemli değil.
Amacım async fonksiyonunu detaylı anlatmak değil.
Ama şimdi ben size desem ki, siz async fonksiyonunu bu şekilde çağırdığınız zaman,
bakın bakın neler gizleniyor sizden.
Siz async fonksiyonunu bu şekilde çağırdığınız zaman aslında belirli bir noktada arka planda bir thread oluşturuyor.
O thread'i ortada stut thread nesnesini hiç görmüyorsunuz değil mi?
Ama arka planda bir thread oluşturuluyor.
O thread bu kolubuluğunu çalıştırıyor.
Ve üstelik sizden gizlenen bir şey daha var.
Bu fonksiyonun geri dönüş değerini ya da bu fonksiyondan bir exception gönderilirse,
onu async fonksiyonuna yaptığınız çağrıdan elde edebiliyorsunuz.
Buradaki detayı tekrar söylüyorum.
Yani arka planda bakın neler gizleniyor.
Thread gizleniyor.
Thread'in arkadaşlar join edilmesi gizleniyor.
Arada işte bugünkü dersimizde oraya kadar ulaşmak istiyorum aslında.
İngilizcesiyle bir shared state paylaşımda bir durum oluşturuluyor.
Ve arka planda o thread çalıştığında oluşacak exception'ı ya da bu thread'i oluşturan koda efendim döndürülecek değerin iletilmesini sağlayan adeta bir kanal gibi düşünün bir shared state oluşturuluyor.
Ve bu fonksiyona çağrı yapan kod bu fonksiyonun bir asenkron olarak örneğin çalıştırılmasından sonra fonksiyonun gönderdiği exception'ı ya da fonksiyonun göndürdüğü geri dönüş değerini kullanabiliyor.
Şimdi yüksek seviye ve alçak seviyeden neden ne denmek istediği açık değil mi?
Arkadaşlar yani bizden az şey gizleniyorsa düşük seviye bizden çok şey gizleniyorsa yüksek seviye ama daha da bakın yüksek seviye izleyin.
Arkadaşlar async'den de daha yüksek seviye neden diyorum?
Siz sort fonksiyonunu çağırıyorsunuz.
Sort fonksiyonunun birinci parametresine paralel çalıştırmak istediğinizi anlatan bir argüman geçiyorsunuz.
Diğer argümanlar normal bizim gördüğümüz sort overloadu gibi.
Yani sort fonksiyonu bu birçok algoritma için geçerli.
Sort fonksiyonunun öyle bir overloadu var ki bu arka planda bu sort işlemini paralel çalıştırmaya yönelik.
Paralel çalıştırmak ne demek?
Arkadaşlar yani siz birden fazla gidiyor arka planda thread oluşturuluyor.
O thread sort işleminin belirli kısımlarını aynı zamanda simultanist yapıyor arkadaşlar.
Ve efendim ondan sonra bunlar bir şekilde arka planda bir algoritma ile birleştiriliyor.
Ve böylece diyelim ki normalde sıralama işlemi x milisaniye sürecekken diyelim ki x bölü 4 milisaniyede bu gerçekleştiriliyor.
Burası anlaşıldı mı?
Evet.
Çağrı.
Çağrı Bey çok güzel bir şeye temas etmiş.
Şimdi diyor ki stu thread de neye göre daha yüksek seviyeli?
Bravo, bravo, bravo.
İşletim sisteminin arkadaşlar kendi thread akülerine göre bu sefer de bizim thread sınıfımız daha yüksek seviyeli.
Çünkü hatırlayın burada C++'ın standart kütüphanesinin sunduğu araçlar aslında onlar da işletim sisteminin apilerini, sistem fonksiyonlarını sarmalıyor.
Yani bu durumda düşük seviyeden yüksek seviyeye doğru gidersek arkadaşlar en düşük seviyede bizden hiçbir şey neredeyse gizlemeyen, bize en ince ayarla her şeyi yapmaya izin veren operating sistemin fonksiyonları var.
Şimdi ben operating sistem diyorum bu işte Unix-Unix sistemlerinde thread aküphanesi olabilir, Windows'da Windows apileri olabilir.
Ama tabii burada bir taşınabilirlik problemi var.
Bize C++'ın efendim standart kütüphanesi bunları sarmalayan öğeler veriyor.
Burada da işte en altta thread sınıfı var.
Ondan daha üstte arkadaşlar async fonksiyonu ve async fonksiyonuyla efendim doğrudan arka planda thread'ı oluşturma,
az önce söylediğim gibi thread'in oluşturacağı, thread'in koşturduğu ve thread'in koşturduğu kolabildan gönderecek exception'ı ya da değeri elde etme arkadaşlar.
Oradan da belki daha yüksek seviye olarak algoritmaların paralel çalıştırılmasını söyleyebiliriz.
Mesela async fonksiyonunun bizden sakladığı bazı şeyleri saklamasını ortadan kaldırmak istiyorsak işte o da inşallah bugünkü dersimizin konusu olacak.
Stood Promise türünden bir nesneyi kendimiz oluşturup bu Stood Promise nesnesinden çalıştırılacak thread'in koşturacağı fonksiyonun geri dönüş değerini
Promise'den elde edilen Future türünden bir nesneden çekiyoruz.
Ama bütün bunları göreceğiz.
Sanırım şimdi bilmiyorum soruyu soran arkadaşlarım iki kişi Rasul Mamedov, bir Deniz Akkuş düşük seviye ya da yüksek seviyeden ne kastettiğimi anlaşıldı mı?
Tıpkı programlama dillerinin düşük seviyelisi ya da yüksek seviyelisi olduğu gibi.
Evet şimdi gelelim arkadaşlar bizim yeni senkronizasyon aracımıza bu aracın ismi Condition Variable.
Arkadaşlar şimdi burada Türkçe eleştirmede bir problem var.
Bu konuda da bir içimi dökmek istiyorum.
Şimdi ne desem birileri şikayetçi oluyor.
Ben bir kere kesinlikle Türkçe'yi savunuyorum.
Türkçe'yi çok seviyorum.
Türkçe'yi çok kullanıyorum.
Türk edebiyatını çok 50 senedir takip ediyorum.
Özellikle Türk şiiri konusunda çok iyi bir okuyucuyum vesaire vesaire.
Fakat şimdi bu özellikle C, C++ tarafında programlamayla ilgili ya da genel terminolojide Türkçe'de bir sorun var.
Terminoloji oluşmadı da.
Keşke oluşmuş olsaydı.
Keşke örneğin biz tıpkı Almanca'da olduğu gibi programlamayla ilgili kendi terminolojimizi Türkçe ortak bir şekilde kurabilseydik.
O kurulmadığı için Türkçe terimler kullanıldığı zaman çok iyi bir anlaşma zemini olmuyor.
Çünkü farklı kişiler İngilizce'deki terimin Türkçe karşılığı olarak farklı terimler kullanılıyor.
Bu da öğrenmeyi zorlaştırıyor.
Resul diyor ki bizde de aynı yani Azeri Türkçesinden bahsediyor.
Resource az olduğu için terminoloji oturmamış.
Ben o yüzden eğitimde de uzun süredir şöyle bir model oluşturmaya çalışıyorum.
Mümkün olduğu kadar Türkçe anlatmak ama aslen İngilizce terminolojiyi kullanmak.
Arada da eğer gerçekten onun bizim en azından Türkiye'de konuştuğumuz Türkçe'de genel kabul görmüş,
oturmuş bir karşılığı varsa onu da belirtmek.
İşte örneğin recursive fonksiyon yerine artık hemen herkesin öz yinelemeli fonksiyon demesi gibi.
Bu sadece bir örnek.
Evet şimdi o zaman tekrar konumuza geri dönelim.
Burada terim condition variable.
Arkadaşlar condition variable birebir çevirirsek koşul değişkeni demek.
Ama burada aslında bir senkronizasyon mekanizmasından bahsediliyor.
Arkadaşlar senkronizasyonu sağlamak için kullanılan işletim sisteminin verdiği temel araçlara aslında synchronization primitive deniyor.
Evet o zaman condition variable da aslında bir synchronization primitive.
Konu biraz dağılmışken bizim ülkede bir arkadaşım yazmış Çağrı Bey yazmış.
Konu biraz dağılmışken bizim ülkede C++ kümelenmesi diğer dillere göre çok az.
Genel bir web teknolojilerine ilgi var.
Avrupa'daki arkadaşlarım C++'ın çok yaygın topluluklarının olduğunu söylüyor.
Özellikle Almanya.
Rasul denemiş ki diyorlar ki ne gerek var tercüme etmeye ama bakıyoruz ki matematik, fizik hepsi tercüme edilmiş.
Evet bizdeki C++ topluluğu biraz daha arkadaşlar a-izole ve sayısal olarak da tabii daha az.
Ama şunu söyleyeyim birçok arkadaşım zaten üye.
Benim kurulcusu olduğum örneğin C++ Türkiye topluluğunun Telegram grubunda yine de yanlış hatırlamıyorsam şu anda 2800 katılımcı var.
Öyle ya da böyle yani grubu takip eden 2800 kişi var.
Bu da az bir sayı değil.
Evet.
Peki condition variable'a şimdi geri döneyim.
Arkadaşlar burada problemin ne olduğunu geçen derste anlatmaya başlamıştım.
Ama tam da böyle kritik yerde dersin sonu geldi.
O yüzden problemi tekrar bir ifade edelim.
Arkadaşlar bu multi-thread programlamada en çok karşımıza çıkan senaryolardan biri bir threadin bir işi gerçekleştirmesi ve o işi gerçekleştirdiği konusunda başka bir threadin bilgilenmesi.
Çünkü başka bir thread mesela şöyle gösterelim bir A-thread'i var.
Genel olarak burada producer terimi kullanılıyor ama illa bir şey üretmesi gerekmiyor.
A-thread'i var.
A-thread'i bir takım işlemleri gerçekleştirdikten sonra aynı zamanda çalışan B-thread'i bundan emin olacak ve A-thread'inin gerçekleştirdiği işlemin sonuçlarından faydalanabilecek.
Bu işlemin sonuçları derken bu herhangi bir şey olabilir.
Mesela A-thread'i bir veriyi hazırlar.
Bu bir string destinesi olabilir.
Bir dosya olabilir.
Bir dosyaya bir şey yazmış olabilir.
Hesaplanacak bir tam sayı, gerçek sayı değeri olabilir.
Ama bütün mesele B-thread'inin kendi işini doğru bir şekilde yapabilmesi için,
yani B-thread'i için oluşturulan algoritmada aslında ne gerekiyor?
A-thread'inin yaptığı işlemin yapılıp tamamlanmış olması ve B-thread'inin bu işlemlerin sonuçları elde edilme garantisiyle işini yapmaya devam etmesi gerekiyor.
B-thread'in ve B-thread'inin eğer A'daki yapılması gereken işlem ya da işlemler, hazırlanması, üretilmesi gereken veri ya da veriler,
onlar üretilmemişse bir şekilde bunu beklemesi gerekiyor.
Şimdi bunu yapmanın bir, arkadaşlar, ne diyelim, ilk akla gelen kötü yolu var.
İkinci, işte bu Condition Variable sınıfını kullanarak, bunu daha az işlemci zamanı alarak yapmanın yolu var.
Ne demek istiyorum?
Aslında ilk akla gelen şu değil mi?
Bu işlemi yapan, veriyi hazırlayan, şimdilik ona producer diyelim, thread,
işlemin yapılıp bittiğine dair ikisinin de ortaklaşa erişebileceği, işte İngilizce burada kullanılan shared state,
bir shared state'i değiştirir.
Bu tipik olarak örneğin Boolean bir değişken olur.
Onun değerinin false olması, işlemin sonuçlarının henüz hazır olmadığı anlamına.
Ama bu shared state, aylaşılan durum olarak kullanılan Boolean değişkenin değerinin true olması da işlemlerin gerçekleştirildiğine işaret eder.
Bu durumda A, tabii ki bu durumda bu shared state olan değişken, örneğimizde Boolean değişken,
hem okuma hem yazma amaçlı kullanıldığı için tabii ki senkronize edilmelidir.
O zaman A işini yaptıktan sonra bir kilit altında o değişkeni set eder, false değerinden true değerine çeker.
Fakat bu arada B thread'i de sürekli arkadaşlar kilidi elde edip o değişkenin true değerine geçip geçmediğini kontrol eder.
Ama burada bizim B thread'imiz sürekli İngilizcesiyle holding yapıyor.
Yani arkadaşlar sürekli aktif hale gelip, bloke olmaktan çıkıp, işlemci zamanını alıp,
tipik olarak döngüsel bir yapıda o Boolean değişkenin, tabii bunun illa bir Boolean değişkeni olması gerekmiyor.
Mesela ortada paylaşılan değişken bir stil string nesnesidir.
Stil string nesnesi boşken dolu hale gelecektir.
İşte paylaşımlı değişken olarak stil string değişkeninin kendisi de kullanılabilir.
Çünkü önemli olan o state değişikliğini gözlememiz.
Mesela o ilk halinde empty ise ama ondan sonra A thread'i işini bitirdikten sonra o paylaşımlı string değişkeni empty olmaktan çıkıyorsa
B thread'i sürekli polling yaparak onun arkadaşlar işinin bitip bitmediğini bu şekilde check edebilir.
Şimdi böyle bir kodu kapımıza canlandırmaya çalışalım demiyorum.
Gerçekten de böyle bir kodu yazmak istesek ortada 3 aşağı 5 yukarı küçük değişiklikler olsa da şöyle bir kodu olacak.
Onu çalışan hale de getirebiliriz.
Bakın bir share state olarak bir değişken kullanacağım.
Genelde bu türden ismi de böyle ready, ready flag vs. olan bir değişken oluşturuyorsunuz.
Bu değişkenin ilk değeri false olacak ki value initialize etseydim şöyle yazsaydım da false olacaktı.
Ama biz yine arkadaşlar bu şekilde yazalım.
Evet ortada bir mutex nesnesi olacak.
Stude mutex mtx ve diyelim ki fun fonksiyonu bu polling yapan fonksiyonu olsun.
Fun fonksiyonu içinde aslında aşağı yukarı şöyle bir aşağı yukarı diyorum bunun türevleri de olabilir anlamında.
Burada fun fonksiyonu arkadaşlar gidecek kilidi edinecek.
Örneğin burada unique lock kullanması ne amaçla unique lock'a ihtiyacımız var yani lock artı olmaz mıydı?
Çünkü birden fazla kez lock-unlock fonksiyonlarını çağırmamız gerekecek tipik olarak.
Efendim o zaman unique lock türünden nesnemizi oluşturalım.
Unique lock, lock ve mutex.
Lock, mutex.
Bu arada zilyonuncu kez söylüyorum burada aslında unique lock'ın bir sınıf şablonu olduğunu C++17 ile gelen sitattan faydalandığımızı söyleyelim.
Yani daha C++17 öncesindeki kodlarda hep şöyle yazıldığını göreceksiniz.
Halen de böyle yazan da olabilir.
Bazıları da işte bu kodun template argümanı görüldüğü için daha açık olduğunu düşünüyor.
Kısmen katılmamak da mümkün değil.
Kız arkadaşlar ama size bırakıyorum tabii ki.
Şimdi ne yapıyor?
İşte burada polling'e geçiyor.
Burada İngilizce'deki poll fiilinin ne anlamda olduğunu biliyoruz değil mi?
Yani sürekli mesela şey hep tipik şu örnek verilir.
Polling.
Mesela diyelim ki biz bir mağazadan aslında çok da güzel bir örnek bu.
Özellikle Anthony Williams'ın Concurrency in Action kitabında bir kitabın bu kadar başarılı olmasının bu kadar sevilmesinin nedenlerinden biri de kitapta hem C++'ın standart Concurrency kütüphanesi anlatılıyor.
Ama diğer taraftan da bu Concurrency'ye ilişkin temel kavramlarda hemen her konuda adam, arkadaşımız adam diyelim bir analoji oluşturmuş.
Mesela geçen derste bu tren istasyon İstanbul'dan Eskişehir'e gelme hikayesi.
O aslında yine Anthony Williams'ın Concurrency in Action kitabında.
Anın burada mesela bir analoji daha.
Polling ne demek ona bir analoji.
Şimdi siz bir ürün bekliyorsunuz bir firmadan.
Fakat o ürün stokta değil ve ürüne de çok ihtiyacınız olduğu için günde 3 kere telefon ediyorsunuz ya da işte mesaj gönderiyorsunuz WhatsApp servisi hatta varsa geldi mi onlar diyor ki henüz gelmedi geldi mi henüz gelmedi.
Ertesi gün oluyor geldi mi henüz gelmedi.
Ama şimdi böyle yapmak yerine ne oluyor?
Şöyle bir sistem de kuruluyor değil mi?
Sen bizi arama biz seni ararız arkadaşlar.
Don't call us will call you.
Sen bizi arama biz seni ararız.
Ne oluyor?
Ürün geldiğinde diyelim ki WhatsApp'tan size mesaj geliyor.
Beklediğiniz ürün gelmiştir.
Artık sizin sürekli sürekli sürekli oraya bir sorgu göndermenize gerek kalmıyor.
Polling'den kast edilen bu.
İşte bu da bir nevi polling.
Peki ne olacak şimdi?
Arkadaşlar bakın burası çok önemli.
Bu kilidi kilitlemesem, mutex'i kilitlemesem şu anda zaten data race olur değil mi?
O yüzden kilitli olmak zorunda.
Şimdi bir while döngüsüne giriyorum.
While değil, ready flag.
Yani ready flag false olduğu sürece.
E şimdi ready flag neden false?
E çünkü diğer thread işini bitirmemiş.
Burada eğer iki threadle aynı mutex'i kullanıyor olmasaydı
böyle bir senkronizasyon da mümkün olmayacaktı.
Aslında bütün bu kavramların en kritiği ve anlaşılması en zoru.
Ona en sona saklıyorum.
Standard'ın synchronized with dediği bir ilişki biçimi.
İki kod arasında İngilizce'de synchronized with yani bir şey ile senkronize edilmiş anlamında.
İşte burada mutex iki thread arasında synchronized with ilişkisi kuruyor.
Bu ne demek?
Aslında en önemli kavram bu ama dediğim gibi en sona saklıyorum.
Synchronized with relationship aslında şu demek.
Yani diğer thread kilit altında yani mutex kilitliyken işlemleri gerçekleştirse kilidi serbest bıraksa
artık o serbest bıraktığı noktadan sonra o kilidi edinen kod
o kilit edinilmişken diğer thread'in yaptığı işlemlerin sonucunu garantibli bir şekilde görmek zorunda.
İşte bakın her zaman onu görmek garanti altında değil.
Ancak senkronizasyon with ilişkisi varsa o garanti veriliyor.
Ve bunu sağlamaya yönelik C++'ın standart kütüphanesinin farklı araçları var.
En temel seviyedeki aracı mutex.
Yani ben mutex'i edinmişsem program state'inde bir takım değişiklikler yapmışsam
mutex'i kilitleyip sonra mutex'in kilidini açmışsam
mutex'i bu sefer çağrı edinip aynı mutex'i tabi arkadaşlar
o mutex'i kilitlemişse çağrı artık neden emin olacak?
Benim yaptığım değişiklikler çağrı kilidi ele geçirdiğinde artık görülebilir durumda olacak.
Yani dil bu garantiyi veriyor.
Ama böyle bir senkronizasyon mekanizması olmadan
arada o kadar çok katman var ki derleyicinin yaptığı optimizasyon,
caching mekanizması, ön bellek mekanizması, işlemci tarafında yapılan optimizasyon
böyle bir garanti yok.
Arkadaşlar konuyu biraz dağıtmak gibi oluyor ama
bakın bakın şu mesela çok tipik bir hata.
İzleyin.
Şimdi thread'lerden biri çalışıyor.
Burada da booleum bir değişken var.
Bull, efendim flag.
Burası çok önemli.
E şimdi bunun diyelim ki değeri boz.
Ve bizim thread'imiz aynı mutex'i kullanmadan bir işlem gerçekleştirip
bu flag'i ruh hale getirse
birer thread'de böyle bir polling yapsa ama bir mutex kullanmasa
işte genelde program yazanların ilk başta
multi-thread programlamada ilk yaptığı tipik hata bu.
şöyle olacağını zannediyorlar.
Ben sürekli soru buluyorsam sonuçta aynı değişken
o false'dan true'ya geçtiğinde
ben onun true değerini yakalayıp
o değişikliklerin yapıldığından emin olabilirim.
İşte burada bir senkronizasyon mekanizmasının olmaması demek
siz o değişkeni
siz o değişkeni true olarak görseniz dahi halen diğer thread'in oluşturduğu sonuçların
gerçekleşmiş olarak sizin thread'iniz tarafından görülebileceği garantisi kesinlikle yok.
bu garantiye elde etmek için mutlaka ve mutlaka bu İngilizcesine
synchronized width garantisini veren araçlardan birini kullanmanız gerekiyor.
ve bu konuda birden fazla araç var.
İşte tekrar konumuza geri dönelim.
Ama en tipik araç
mutex'te iki farklı thread'in
aynı mutex'i kullanıyor olması.
Peki şimdi ne yapacak?
Eğer flag halen false durumdaysa
arkadaşlar
ben gideceğim
kilidi
açacağım ki
diğer thread yine aynı kilidi
kullanabilsin. Çünkü ben lock durumda tuttuğum sürece
başkası edinemez.
Hatta burada
duruma göre
arkadaşlar
bu tabii garanti değil ama
benim thread'ime öncelik verilmesin diye
daha önce görmüştük
stut
this thread
namespace'indeki
yield fonksiyonunu da çağırabilirsiniz.
Ama burada
ya da tipik bir yol
arkadaşlar
belirli süre
uyumak.
Peki ne kadar uyuyacağız?
Burada iki tane problem var.
Birincisi
tamam burada ben
uyuyorum
bloke oluyorum
ama bu işlem sürekli sürekli
yapıldığı için
yine işlemci kaynağını yiyor.
Arkadaşlar
this thread
sleep for
diyelim ki
chrono
şöyle diyelim
arkadaşlar
şu chrono
bizim için şöyle bir problem
oluşturuyor.
Sürekli
chrono'nun kendisinin
namespace olduğu için
chrono'nun
duration
türünün
arkadaşlar
demek yerine
aslında
biraz
zararlı olduğunu da
söyleyemeyiz.
her zaman
using
direktifi
kötüdür
demek de
çok tipik bir yanılgı.
Ben tipik olarak şöyle yazıyorum.
Hangi namespace'i
hangi namespace için
using
direktifi
kullanıyorum?
Using
namespace
stood
letters
ama tabii size
kullanın ya da
kullanmayın
anlamına
gelmiyor.
İster kullanın
ister kullanmayın.
Tabii ki
sonuçta bir isim
çatışması
riski
yine var.
Şimdi artık
bu namespace
için
using
direktifi
kullandığımda
doğrudan
ne yapabilirim?
bu
literal
operatörü
kullanabilirim.
Şimdi ama
ne yapacağım?
Şimdi tekrar
kilitli edineceğim.
Lock
İşte böyle.
Bak
burada bir başka
problem
ha
yanlış anlaşılmasın
bakın böyle
olur mu?
Olur.
İsterseniz
deneyelim.
Bakınız
şimdi
stud
mutex
int
data
yani bu
diğer thread'in
üretici
veriyi
temsil etsin
ve
p ile çalışan
bir örnek
yapmakta
fayda var.
Arkadaşlar
buna
izin
receiver
diyelim
sözde
ya da user
diyelim
ve
bu döngüden
çıktığı zaman
iostream
arkadaşlar
şunu yazdırsın
see out
i
i am
using
the
nasıl
ingilizce
ama
the value
now
desin
ve
value'yu da
yazdırsın
data
çünkü artık
emin
bunun
hazır olduğunda
şimdi
receiver
ya da
consumer
demek belki
daha güzel
bu örnek için
consumer
data
consume
ediyor
tüketiyor
diğeri de
producer
void
da
stud
lock
guard
kilidiye
dindi
ve
arkadaşlar
data'yı
değiştirdi
data
eşittir
hep 42
kullanıyormuş
ben de
bazı
şeylerde de
benim cehaletim
neğer
nereden geldiğini
sonradan
bu kurstan
bir arkadaşım
söylemişti
evet
şu meşhur
herkesin
sevdiği
kitaptan
neyse
kitabın
ismini
yine
unuttum
galaksi
rehberi
ona benzer
bir şey
oradan
geliyormuş
o da
iki
değeri
evet
ben de
öğrenmiş oldum
data
eşittir
ve
red
flag
eşittir
true
bakın
şimdi
buraya kadar
derleyelim
bir eksik
bir şey
olmasın
ve
main
fonksiyonu
içinde
stut
c
thread
foo
t1
stut
ch
thread
foo
değil
yazıyorum
neydi
consumer
mi
demiştim
consumer
stut
ch
thread
p2
producer
şimdi
lütfen
dikkat
bunun
herhangi bir
şekilde
bu programı
koşturduğum
zaman
producer
thread'in
arkadaşlar
yukarıda
datayı
üretmesinden
önce
bu
consumer
thread'in
o datayı
kullanma
girişimi
söz konusu
mu
hayır işte
bu
synchronized
with
relationship
aynı
mutex üstünde
kullanılan
kilitleme
ve kilidi
açma
işlemlerinin
bu garantiyi
synchronized
with
garantisine
verdiğini
söyledim
efendim
çalıştıralım
bakın
I'm using
the value
now
nasıl bir ihtimal
burada yok
Rusul
mesela
programı
yüz kere
bin kere
on bin kere
çalıştırıyorum
ama bir tanesinde
I'm using
the value
now
ve
data
örneğin
sıfır
değeriyle
geliyor
böyle bir ihtimal
yok
şimdi burada
tekrar buraya
geri döncek
olursak
bu çalışır mı
çalışır
yani bunda
bir problem yok
yapmak istediğiniz
buysa
bunu yapabilirsiniz
ve bunu yapmak
her zaman kötü
de diyemem
neden
mesela
burada şöyle bir şey
de olabilir
belki de istediğiniz
gerçekten bu
yani şu
unlock
ve lock
arasında
arkadaşlar
siz
paylaşımda
değişken
üstünde değil
bir takım
başka şeyler
yapmak istiyor
olabilirsiniz
yani bu her zaman
kötüdür
illa burada
condition variable
kullanılmalı
diyemiyorum
değil mi
şimdi
condition variable
neyi sağlıyor
aynı
condition variable
bir sınıf
sınıfı türünden
bir nesne
arkadaşlar
adı üstünde
bir koşul değişkeni
bir başka
bir threadin
bu koşul değişkeni
iki ayrı thread
aynı koşul değişkenini
aynı condition variable
kullanarak
aralarında
bir haberleşme
sağlıyor
arkadaşlar
efendim
condition variable
kullanan
o producer
diyebileceğimiz
thread
aslında
condition variable
kullanarak
bir
notification
ingilizce de böyle
deniyor
notify
fiili
adeta bir
sinyal gönderiyor
ey
beni
bekleyen
uyumakta olan
thread ya da
threadler
şimdi
uyan
eğer
tek
threadse
ya da
hepiniz
uyanın
hepinizin
beklediği
data
hazır
böylece
consumer olan
thread
condition variable
kullanarak
kendisini
uyutuyor
ve neden
emin artık
condition variable
veri hazır
olduğunda
diğer thread
condition variable
aynı condition variable
üstünden
bekleyeni
uyandırıyor
işte bizim
o tren
örneğimizde
olduğu gibi
ikide bir
istasyona
geldik mi
diye kontrol
etmek yerine
kondüktör
geliyor
uyumakta olan
Necati'yi
kaldırıyor
bak diyor
senin
işin hazır
tren
Eskişehir'e
geldi
diyor
örneğin
evet
Alian
Bozkır
26.
satırdaki
unlock
etme
producer
işine
devam
edebilsin
diye mi
tabii ki
çünkü
bakınız
producer'ın
ne noktada
bu işi
bitireceği
garanti
altında
değil ki
dolayısıyla
producer
bu
shared
state'i
bir kilit
altında
değiştirmek
durumunda
ama
bizde
aynı kilidi
kullandığımızda
artık
burayla
senkronize
olduğumuz için
buranın
ürettiği
sonucu
kullanabilecek
durumdayız
dolayısıyla
işe
devam
edebilmesi
için
tekrar
kilide
edinmesi
gerekiyor
yoksa
biz
kilidi
tutarsak
o zaman
onun bize
haber verme
şansı
olmaz
yani
işi
belki
yapar
anlaşıldı
değil mi
bize haber verme
şansı
olmaz
dolayısıyla
kilidi
serbest
bırakmamız
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
bu kod
gayet güzel
şimdi
condition
variable
şöyle bir
daha
sentaksına
üye fonksiyonlara
girmeden
bir temel
düzeyde
anlatalım
ortada
bir değişken
var
işte bu
değişkenin
türü
condition
variable
bu arada
condition
variable
ayrı bir
başlık
dosyası
var
yani
condition
variable
kullanabilmem
için
benim
condition
variable
başlık
dosyasını
include
etmem
gerekiyor
condition
variable
bir
sınıf
şablonu
değil
yani
jenerik
bir sınıf
değil
dolayısıyla
condition
variable
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesneyi
doğrudan
şöyle
oluşturacağım
ve yine
condition
variable
hem
arkadaşlar
veriyi
hazırlayanın
hem de
işte o
işlemlerin
sonucunu
veriyi
ne derseniz
bekleyenin
ortaklaşa
erişebileceği
bir değişken
olması
lazım
o yüzden
tipik olarak
global
değişken
oluyor
arkadaşlar
ya da
global
değişken
değilse
bir şekilde
onu
referans
ematiyle
aktarmak
gerekiyor
şimdi
condition
variable
kullanan
kod
yani
datayı
hazırlayan
kod
ne yapacak
arkadaşlar
condition
variable
kullanarak
datayı
hazırlayacak
ama tabi
bunu bir kilit
altında
yapacak
ve
bu
datayı
hazırlayan
kodun
kullandığı
kilidin
kilit derken
burada
işte o
lock
card
scope
onlardan
bahsediyorum
herhangi bir
sınıf
olabilir
ama
onu
bekleyen
aynı
condition
variable
kullanacak
ama
unique
lock
kullanmak
zorunda
burası
önemli
neden
çünkü
arka
planda
o
wait
dediğimiz
operasyonda
arka
planda
biz
görmesek
de
aslında
mutex
kilitleniyor
açılıyor
bu şekilde
evet
peki
o zaman
ilk örneğimize
başlayalım
arkadaşlar
izleyin
mesela
demik örneği
condition
variable
uygulayalım
efendim
mutex
başlık
dosyasını
condition
variable
başlık
dosyasında
krono
başlık
dosyasına
asla
eklenmeye
gerek
yok
çünkü
biliyorsunuz
mutex
başlık
dosyası
o
duration
ve
time point
türlerini
kullandığı
için
mecbur
neyi
include
etmek
zorunda
krono
başlık
dosyasını
include
etmek
zorunda
ve
iostream
başlık
dosyasını
da
ekleyin
ve
using
namespace
stut
vpros
hazır
olsun
kullanırız
arkadaşlar
bakın
şimdi
bu üretici
void
producer
üretici gidiyor
önce
bu arada
burada
bekleme
sağlayalım ki
diğerinin
beklemeye
geçmesi için
bir zaman
tanıyalım
stop this
stress
sleep for
diyelim ki
bin
milisaniye
evet
şimdi
kilidi edineceğim
ediniyor
üretici
kilidi edinirken
herhangi bir
lock
kullanabilir
yani
scope
lock
da olabilir
guard
mesela ben
lock
guard
kullanıyorum
normalde
scope
lock
kullanıyorum
artık
lock
guard
kullandığım
her yerde
lock
guard
gidiyelim
lock
arkadaşlar
bir tane yine
mutex olmak zorunda
scoot
mutex
mtx
slot guard
lock
mutex
mtx
tamam
şimdi burada
işte
burayı şöyle
soyutlayalım
production code
evet
ama
bizim o
production
kodumuz
sözde olduğu için
hazırlanacak
veri için
şöyle bir şey
yapalım
mesela
int
shared
variable
diğerinin
beklediği
diğer
bu
kartından
temsil edilsin
evet
şimdi
ve
shared
variable
arkadaşlar
eşittir
takip edin
evet
ve
izleyin
şimdi
condition
variable
ilk önce
ne yapacak
bir tane
condition
variable
kullanacak
o
condition
variable
da
kullanalım
evet
şimdi
şunu
bir
scope
içine
alalım
neden
aldığımı
söyleyeceğim
çünkü
bakın
bu
condition
variable
kullanarak
notification
gönderme
işleminin
kilit altında
yapılması
gerekmiyor
hatta
kilit altında
yapılmaması
efficiency
açısından
önemli
şimdi
artık
burada
kilit
bırakılmış
oldu
ve
condition
variable
arkadaşlar
ismini
oluşturmamışız
smooth
condition
variable
ben tipik olarak
cv ismini
veriyorum
condition
variable
ve
condition
variable
iki fonksiyondan
birini çağırmam
gerekiyor
çağıracağım fonksiyonlardan
biri
notify
one
diğeri
notify
all
işte bakın fonksiyonlara
ya notify
one
ya da
arkadaşlar
notify
all
fonksiyonlarından
birini çağırıyorsunuz
aradaki fark
şu
hepsine o kadar çok örnek
yazabilirdim ki
hepsini
göreceksiniz
notify
one
fonksiyonu
sadece
bir
thread'i uyandırıyor
mesela bekleyen
aynı
condition
variable
üstünden
bekleyen
10 tane
thread varsa
siz
notify
one
fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
thread'lerden
sadece
birini
uyandırıyorsunuz
ve hangisinin
uyanacağı
yine
deterministik
değil
ama
notify
one
yerine
notify
all
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsanız
aynı
condition
bu cümleyi sürekli
tekrar ediyorum
aynı
condition
variable
üstünde
bekleyen
bütün
şeyleri
thread'leri
uyandırıyorsunuz
dolayısıyla
eğer
bir tanesini
uyandırmak
istiyorsunuz
ya da
zaten
uyandırılacak
bir tane
thread varsa
notify
one
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsunuz
ve tekrar
söylüyorum
bu
çağrının
kilit
altında
olması
gerekmiyor
olursa
bir şey
fark etmez
olsa olsa
o da
derleyiciye
bağlı
belki
bir verim
kaybı
olabilir
olması
gerekmiyor
yani pekala
bu çağrıyı
burada da
yapabilirdim
yapabilirim
ve burada
bir önemli
nokta
daha
bu
işlemi
hazırlayan
bekleyenden
bahsetmiyorum
işlemi hazırlayan
burada
arkadaşlar
lockable
olarak
lock
card da
kullanabilir
scope
card da
kullanabilir
scope
lock da
kullanabilir
arkadaşlar
efendim
unique
lock da
kullanabilir
shape lock da
herhangi
bir
lockable
bunlara
deniyor
İngilizce'de
bu kadar
e şimdi
consumer'a
bakalım
arkadaşlar
şimdi burası
biraz enteresan
word
consumer
arkadaşlar
arka plandaki
işlem şu
değil mi
tabi bunları
işletim sisteminde
sistem fonksiyonları
yapıyorum
notify one
fonksiyonu
çağrıldığında
adı üstünde
uyuyan
thread ya da
threadler için
not çağrının
notify one
ya da
notify all
olmasına bağlı
olarak
onları
uyandıracak
adeta
bir sinyal
gönderiliyor
şimdi
birazdan
göreceğiz
o
uyumakta
olan
thread
bu
sinyali
alınca
uyanıyor
uyanınca
kilidi
yine
mutex
yine kilitliyor
dolayısıyla
ondan sonraki
işlemler
yine
o kilitlenmiş
mutex
altında
yapılıyor
yani
bizim
bekleyen
threadimiz
uyanınca
artık
shared
data'ya
erişmesi
bir
data
risk
tehlikesi
riski
içermiyor
yalnız burada
iki tane
problem var
problemlerden
bir tanesi
arkadaşlar
burası
biraz karmaşık
ama
yine de
anlatmaya
çalışayım
arkadaşlar
şimdi
burada
arka planda
işletim
sisteminin
fonksiyonları
kullanılıyor
ve bir
notifikasyon
gönderildiği
zaman
şöyle bir
endişe
var
uyuyan
thread'in
bu
notifikasyonu
sinyali
ya da
notifikasyonu
ne derseniz
kaçırmaması
gerekiyor
işte
onu
kaçırmaması
için
maalesef
ingilizcede
spurious
wake up
denilen
durum
oluşma
potansiyelinde
spurious
wake up
şu demek
normalde
birazdan
kodunu yazacağız
thread'i uyutacağız ya
bizim beklediğimiz
sonuç
oluşuncaya
kadar
thread'i
bloke edeceğiz ya
aslında
ideal olsaydı
ne zaman
arkadaşlar
uyanacaktı
notifikasyon
gönderildiği
zaman
fakat işte
arka plandaki
kodlar
maalesef
bu işletim
sistemiyle
ilgili bir
mekanizma
isterseniz
orayı da
daha sonra
ayrıntılı
anlatırım
karşı tarafın
bunu
kaçırma
riskini
ortadan
kaldırmak
için
bazen
ne göndermek
zorunda
kalabiliyor
aslında
ortada
bir
notifikasyon
olmadan
bizim
beklemekte
olan
thread'imiz
uyanabiliyor
yani
beklemekte
olan
thread
iki
nedenle
uyanabilir
biri
gerçekten
notifikasyon'ı
aldığı için
zaten
amaç bu
diğeri de
notifikasyon
almamasına
rağmen
işte
işletim
sistemi
düzeyinde
bazı
nedenlerden
arkadaşlar
yine
uyanıyor
yani
bu durumda
eğer
bundan
kaçınmak
istiyorsanız
o
uyanması
durumunun
İngilizcesiyle
spurious
wake up
mı
buradaki
spurious
niteliğcisi
İngilizce'de
sahte
vesaire
gibi bir
anlam
yani
sahte
bir
uyanma
mı
yoksa
gerçek
uyanma
mı
olduğunu
bir
şekilde
ayırt
etmesi
gerekiyor
onun
nasıl
yapıldığını
birazdan
göreceğiz
yoksa
şöyle
bir
problem
oluyor
eğer
spurious
wake up
olursa
ki
bu
kullanıcı
thread
consumer
açısından
spurious
wake up
tamamen
random
yani
spurious
wake up
önceden
öngörülemeyecek
şekilde
olabilir
olmayabilir
şu kadar
sürede
olabilir
daha
geç
olabilir
bu
tamamen
kullanışı
consumer
thread
açısından
arkadaşlar
deterministik
değil
dolayısıyla
neyi de
sağlamanız
gerekiyor
spurious
wake up
söz
konusu
mu
eğer söz
konusuysa
uyandım
ama
yanlış
uyandım
o yüzden
benim
tekrar
uykuya
dalmam
gerekiyor
burada
şuna
dikkat etmek
gerekiyor
spurious
wake up
olabilir
ya da
olmayabilir
ama
olma
ihtimalini
mutlaka
göz önüne
almanız
gerekiyor
eğer
spurious
wake up
olursa
o zaman
şöyle bir
problem
arkadaşlar
siz bunu
dikkate
almazsanız
sizin
threadiniz
uyanacak
fakat
aslında
o sonuçlar
henüz
oluşmamış
durumda
bu
çok daha
büyük bir
problem
evet
peki
şimdi
gelelim
consumer'a
arkadaşlar
şimdi
consumer'ın
aynı
mutex'i
kullanması
gerekiyor
fakat
arka
planda
consumer
thread'in
charge'a
wait
fonksiyonunun
kilidi
birden fazla
kez
mutex'i
birden fazla
kez
kilitleyip
tekrar
kilidi
açması
gerekiyor
hatırlayınız
lock
card
buna
doğrudan
izin
vermiyor
ne izin
veriyor
buna
hangi
lockable
izin
veriyordu
unique
lock
o yüzden
consumer
tarafında
unique
lock'ın
kullanılması
mecburi
evet
şimdi
burada da
şöyle bir
yine
nested scope
oluşturalım
ne yapıyoruz
stut
unique
lock
arkadaşlar
yine
lock
mutex
aynı mutex'i
kesinlikle
kullanmak
zorundayız
şimdi
kilidi aldık
nasıl
uyuyacağız
işte
burada
kendimizi
uyutmak
için
arkadaşlar
wait
fonksiyonu
var
ama
bu
kimin
wait
fonksiyonu
condition
variable'ın
wait
fonksiyonu
condition
variable'ın
wait
fonksiyonuna
arkadaşlar
bizim
lockable
nesnemizi
argüman olarak
geçiyoruz
yani
bunu da
argümanı
lock olarak
geçiyoruz
ama şimdi
böyle bir
kod yazarsak
buraya
dikkat
serious
wake
up
mustarip
olabiliriz
yani
bu durumda
wait
fonksiyonu
çağırıldı
bu arada
diğer
thread
notification'ı
göndermeden
biz
bu
wait
fonksiyonudan
sonra
uyandık
tekrar
kilidi
edindik
fakat
data
hazır değil
böyle bir
ihtimal de var
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
şimdi
bu ihtimali
devreden
çıkarmak için
iki tane yol var
birincisi
wait
fonksiyonunun
bu
overloadunu
kullanmak
yani
wait
fonksiyonunun
bu
overloadu
gördüğünüz gibi
bizden
sadece
neyi alıyor
lockable
yani
oradaki
lock nesnesini
alıyor
eğer bunu
alırsa
biz
spurious
wake up
oldu mu
olmadı mı
kontrolünü
döngüsel bir
yapı içinde
kendimiz
yapmak
zorundayız
o döngüsel
yapıda
aslında
şöyle olacak
arkadaşlar
bir tane daha
yine
bizim
shared
state'imiz
olacak
bool
diyelim ki
ready flag
bunun
ilk değeri
false
olacak
arkadaşlar
ve
burada
bir döngüye
girip
ready flag
false
olduğu sürece
tekrar
biz
beklemeye
devam edeceğiz
yani
wait fonksiyonunu
döngüsel bir yapı
içinde
çağırırız
yani şöyle bir kod
olacak
izleyin
arkadaşlar
while
ready flag
false
olduğu sürece
biz
wait fonksiyonunu
tekrar tekrar
çağıracağız
buraya dikkat
bu durumda
producer
kod
arkadaşlar
notify
one
çağrısını
yapmadan
önce
bu kilit
altında
ready flag
true
değerini
çekecek
başlangıçta
biraz karmaşık
her öğrenin
üstünde
bu karmaşıklık
söz konusu
o yüzden
biraz sabırlı
olmanızı
istiyorum
evet
ama şimdi
bakınız
bu kodu
yazmak
daha zor
daha zahmetli
ve ne derler
bir boilerplate
kodu olduğu için
bunu
sarmalayan
bir başka
wait fonksiyonu
daha veriyor
standart
kütüphane
o wait fonksiyonu
da şöyle
arkadaşlar
artık
döngü falan
oluşturmuyorsunuz
doğrudan
bu
condition variable'un
wait fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsunuz
yine
wait fonksiyonunun
birinci parametresine
yine
lockable
nesnesine
geçiyorsunuz
ama
ikinci parametresi
görüyor musunuz
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir
göstermek istiyorum
ikinci parametresi
gördüğünüz gibi
bir predikat
predikat ne demekti
bool döndüren
bir callable
siz şimdi
fonksiyonun
ikinci parametresine
bool döndüren
bir callable'ı
argüman olarak
vereceksiniz
artık
az önce
yazdığınız
koddaki
döngü
wait fonksiyonu
içinde
olacak
yani siz örneğin
şöyle yazarsanız
tipik olarak
burada bir
lambda expression
kullanıyorum
çünkü sadece
burada kullanacağım
bir callable'a
ihtiyacım var
aslında bütün
callable'lar
olabilir
ama tabi burada
ideali
arkadaşlar
lambda expression
kullanmak
peki lambda expression
ne olacak
bir şekilde
haberleşmesi
lazım
mesela
return
ready flag
şimdi ne oluyor
burada
aslında az önceki
döngüyü
burası oluşturmuş
oluyor
şöyle ki
eğer
wait fonksiyonu
bir notification
geldiğinde
bizim
condition
variable'ımız
bu consumer
trade'i
uyandırdığı
zaman
kilit elde ediliyor
kilit altında
predicate function
çağrılıyor
true değer elde
ederse
biz yine
kiliti edinmiş
oluyoruz
ve artık
bloke
olmaktan
çıkıyoruz
yani bizim
trade'imiz
burada
koşmaya
devam edecek
ama
diyelim ki
bir
spurious
wake up
oldu
spurious
wake up
olduysa
o zaman
artık bizim
neden eminiz
red flag'imiz
false durumda
olacak
ve tekrar
uyuyacak
tekrar kiliti
serbest
bırakacak
dolayısıyla
kod
alahan diyor ki
çok daha
soyut ve güzel
gerçekten de
çok daha
soyut ve güzel
şimdi artık
programın akışı
buraya geldiğinde
buraya dikkat
arkadaşlar
programın akışı
buraya geldiğinde
şunlardan eminiz
kilit bizde
olduğu için
yani biz
kilitlemiş durumdayız
consumer
trade olarak
biz kilitlemiş olduğumuz
için
artık
arkadaşlar
eş zamanlı
olarak
kimin
paylaşımlı
veri ya da
verilere erişme
şansı yok
diğer trade
ya da
trade'lerin
erişme
şansı yok
yani ben
burada
örneğin
shared
variable'ı
kullanırsam
stut
see out
arkadaşlar
value
is
ready
ve
neydi değişkenimizin
ismi
shared
variable
şimdi durum
biraz daha karışık
gibi görünüyor
ama
çok büyük bir
fayda elde ediliyor
yani biz
doğrudan
işlemci zamanını
almadık
sonuç
oluşana kadar
uyuma
durumundayız
arkadaşlar
gerçekten de
buraya kadar
bir derleyelim
hepsini anlatacağım
biraz sabırlı
olursak
en çok
sorulan
sorular
gerçekten
bu
condition
variable
üstünde
yani
kütüphanenin
diğer
ne diyelim
bileşen
bileşenleri
concurrency
C++
standart kütüphanesi
biraz daha açık
anlaşılması
daha kolay
arkadaşlar
burada
biraz
anlaşılması
sorulacak
soru
sayısı
fazla
isten şimdi
thread oluştunuz
do thread
t1
hep c thread
de kullanmayayım artık
producer
consumer
bunu çoktandır
kullanmadık
t1 join
t2 join
evet
bakın value
is ready
burada
artık bu garanti var
şimdi
alamein
sorusuna
bakalım
o zaman
peki producer
19. satırda
true
yaptı
19. satırda
true
yaptı
19. satırda
true
yaptığında
bir şey
dikkat
daha sorunun
devamını
okumadan
19. satırda
true
yaptığı zaman
biz henüz
notification'ı
göndermemiş
durumdayız
bir
yani
notify
one
ve notify
ya da notify
one
all
çağrısını
zaten
bundan sonra
yapıyoruz
bu bir
yani sorunu
devamlı
okumadan
iki
gerek
burada
ready
flag'in
true
değerine
çekilmesi
gerek
burada
shared
variable'ın
set edilmesi
her ikisi de
paylaşımlı
değişken
shared
variable
mutex
kilitliyken
yapılıyor
yani burada
date arayısı
olma ihtimali de
yok
evet
hocam peki
producer
19. satırda
true yaptı
20. satıra
geçer
geçmez
sahte
bir uyanma
gerçekleşti
evet
sahte bir
uyanma
gerçekleşti
bunu nasıl
kontrol edebiliriz
sonuçta
consumer
ready flag'i
kontrol ederek
bunu kontrol
edebiliyor
arkadaşlar
evet
ben soruyu
anlamamış
olabilirim
işte zaten
verilen garanti
bu
şimdi burada
wait fonksiyonu
biz böyle görüyoruz
ama
buranın üstünden
bir daha geçelim
bakın wait fonksiyonu
karşılığı
ne oluyor
yavaş yavaş
gidelim
bir
wait fonksiyonu
çağrıldı
çağrıldığı
zaman
arkadaşlar
bizim
normalde
wait fonksiyonu
çağırdığımız zaman
zaten bunu
kilit altında
çağırıyoruz
yani şu anda
mutex'in kilidi
bizde
alayan
şimdi
wait fonksiyonu
çağrıldığı zaman
kilit
açılıyor
biz görmesek de
lock'ın
arkadaşlar
unlock fonksiyonu
çağırılıyor
yani wait fonksiyonu
bunun koduna
bakarsanız
orada
bizim
argüman olarak
gönderdiğimiz
lock
nesnesinin
unlock fonksiyonu
çağrılıyor
unlock fonksiyonunun
çağrılmasıyla
birlikte
bizim
thread'imiz
arkadaşlar
bloke oluyor
uyumaya başlıyor
yani önce kilidi
serbest bırakıyor
ondan sonra
uyumaya başlıyor
takip edebiliyor muyuz
bir
wake up
oluştuğunda
a
eğer
spurious
wake up'sa
o zaman
biz yine
kilidi
ediniyoruz
çünkü
halen
unique lock
nesnemiz var
kilidi
kilitliyoruz
ve
arkadaşlar
bu
callable'ı
çağırıyoruz
bu callable
eğer
true değer
dönerse
burada
artık
uyanıyoruz
kilit
bizde
ve bundan sonraki
işlemleri
kilit altında
yapıyoruz
ve
predikatimiz
true değer
döndüğünde
artık neden
eminiz
notification
geldi
veri hazır
diğer thread'in
aynı
condition
variable
üstünden
çalışan
diğer thread'in
işini
bizim beklediğimiz
işi
görevi ne derseniz
bitirdiğini
anlıyoruz
ama
spurious
wake up olursa
şimdi
alianın sorusu
burayla ilgili
spurious
wake up olursa
burada
callable
false
değerine
dönüyor
false
değeri
döndürdüğünde
yine
unlock
fonksiyonu
çağırılıyor
ve biz yine
bloke oluyoruz
yani bu
arka planda
az önce
söylediğim gibi
bir
döngü
var
arkadaşlar
burada
belki biraz daha
detay
bir problem
daha var
aslında burada
böyle bir
predikat
kullanmak
bir başka
problemi de
çözüyor
o probleme de
lost
wake up
deniyor
yani aslında
burada
condition
variable ile ilgili
iki tane
problem var
ben problemlerden
birini söyledim
buna
spurious
wake up
deniyor
diğeri
ona
şimdi
girmek
istemiyorum
ona da
lost
wake up
deniyor
ama
sadece
bilmemiz gereken
şu
eğer biz
böyle bir
predikat
kullanırsak
ya da işte
döngüsel yapı
içinde
predikat
sorgulama
yaparsak
her ikisine
karşı da
önlem
almış oluyoruz
şimdi burada
aslında
sizin yerinize
ben
birden fazla
soru
soracağım
arkadaşlar
bakınız
bir
buradaki
mekanizma
bir kerelik
bir mekanizma
olmak zorunda
değil
yani örneğin
pred
nereden biri
ya da birden
fazlası
sürekli
ne gönderebilir
notification
gönderebilir
diğeri de
sürekli
arkadaşlar
beklemeye
geçip
diğeri
veriyi
hazırladı
bizimki
uyandı
kullandı
sonra
tekrar uyudu
diğeri
tekrar
veri hazırladı
uyandı
yani bu
bir kere
olmak zorunda
değil
mesela
ilerleyen dakikalarda
ben kendi hazırladığım
birkaç tane örnek
göstereceğim
mesela veri yapıları
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
öyle bir veri yapısı ki
list
ama
bir yandan
bir thread
listeye
liste derken
bir konteynerdan
bahsediyorum
bir veri yapısı
kullanan bir thread
listeye
ö ekliyor
öbürü de
listeden
öye çekiyor
ama
listeden
öye çekmesi için
listenin
boş olmadığından
emin olması lazım
o zaman
ne oluyor
bir thread
liste
boş olduğu
sürece
bekleyecek
ne zamanki
uyanacak
uyandığında
artık
listede
en az bir tane
öye olduğunu
anlayacak
ve onu
listeden
çıkartacak
biri listeye
konteynera
öye ekliyor
diğeri de
öyeyi
çekiyor
yani bu sürekli
producer
consumer
ilişkisi
döngüsel bir yapıda
birden fazla
kez
gerçekleşebiliyor
yani ne yapıp
ne yapamayacağımızı
anlamak da
çok önemli
çünkü
başlangıçta
hep de
örnekler
böyle toy
example
olduğu için
kişiyi
biraz
sınırlandırıyor
mesela şu
olabilir mi
tahmin edin
olur ya da
olmaz
deyin
şu olabilir mi
mesela
iki tane
yine
polu polu var
biri
veriyi
üretti
öbürü
notification
gönderdi
öbürü
kullandı
bu sefer
kullanan
bir işlem
yaptı
notification
gönderdi
bu sefer de
diğeri
onun sonucunu
kullandı
yani
adeta
ping pong
gibi
ben oluşturuyorum
çağrı
kullanıyor
sonra çağrı
bir işlem yapıyor
onun sonucundan
ben faydalanıyorum
bir ben
bir çağrı
bu durumda
bunu şunun için
söylüyorum
illa
birinin
producer
diğerinin
consumer
olması
gerekmiyor
yani her iki
polu
da
koşturulacak
her iki
ne diyelim
iş yükü
de
ne yapabilir
hem
arkadaşlar
veriyi hazırlayıp
diğerini
bundan
haberdar
edebilir
aynı zamanda
diğeri de bir işlem
yapıp
bizimkini
haberdar
edebilir
buraya kadar
umarım
anlaşıldı
şimdi ben
bundan sonra
bazı örnekleri
hazır olarak
vereceğim
çünkü
yazma zamanı
yine maalesef
çok uzun olur
çok da fazla örnek
göstermek istiyorum
mümkün olduğu
kadar fazla
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
izleyin
az önce
söylediğimi
göstermeye yönelik
şöyle bir örnek
hazırladım
şimdi burada
iStack
isimli bir
sınıf var
yani normal
necati
stack
sınıfı
zaten var
değil mi
tabii tabii
ama
hatırlayın
STL
konteynerları
ve konteyner adaptörleri
kesinlikle
thread safe
değil
bir kere
onu bir
hatırlatmak istiyorum
fakat burada
öyle bir
stack
oluşturacağız
ki
işte
threadlerden
birden fazla
thread kullanabilecek
bir thread
siteye
push yaparken
başka bir
thread de
stackten
pop işlemi
yapabilecek
mehmet
alege
keci
hocam
bu örneklere
bakarsak
sanki
thread
kullanmayıp
main'de
iki fonksiyon
çağırmak
daha doğru
ben bir şey mi
kaçırıyorum
evet bir şey
kaçırıyorsunuz
bir şey
derken
söylediğiniz
yanlış anlamında
değil
tekrar buraya
gelelim
arkadaşlar
burada
kaçırdığınız şey
şu
buraya dikkat
bunlar
bu örnekte onu
göstermiyoruz
ama bunlar
sonuçta
senkron
çalışmıyor
asenkron
çalışıyor
yani bir yandan
bu thread
koşuyor
bir yandan
bu thread
koşuyor
şimdi
şunu
demek istiyorum
Mehmet Ali
siz
buradaki
koklar
sadece
bizim
ilgilendiren
kısımla
ilgili olduğu için
burası önemli
siz sanki
bunun
senkron
çalışmasıyla
asenkron
çalışması
arasında
bir fark
yokmuş
gibi
görüyorsunuz
haklı olarak
bir sonraki örnek
onu daha iyi
anlatacak
oysa
bakınız
mesela
consumer thread
burada da
işlemler var
belki
anladınız
değil mi
e-share
variable
aldı
ama bu
bir dakika
yoluna
devam ediyor
halen
burada
işlemler
var
burayı
anladık
mı
ben örneğin
sadece
örneğin
condition
variable
kısmını
gösterdiğim için
Mehmet Ali
sizde böyle bir izlenim
uyandı
ve o da haklı
yani kod bu kadar
olsaydı
arkadaşım sonuna kadar
haklı
biri
üretirdi
o
senkron çalışırdı
bittikten sonra
bizimki çalışırdı
şimdi
bir tek
Mehmet Ali
Bey için
söylemiyorum
bütün arkadaşlarım için
söylüyorum
espriyi
anladınız
değil mi
ben size
kodun bu
kısmını
gösteriyorum
oysa
producerda
burada da
kod var
bakın
burada da
kod var
notify one
deyince
işi bitmiyor
ki
belki hatta
bu koddan
önce de
aynı
foundation
variable
kullanıp
şöyle de
olabilir
bakın bu da çok tipik bir senaryo
şimdi büyük resmi
görmeye çalışacağım
bu
dediğim gibi
toy örnek
şu olabilir miydi
şurada gösterelim
mesela bu bizim
producerımız
bir takım kodları
çalıştırdı
şimdi
notification
gönderdi
böylece
bu
notification
gönderilince
diğer thread
buraya kadar olan
işlemlerin
sonucunu
aldı
e burada
yine kod var
arkadaşlar
tekrar
notification
gönderdi
burada yine
kod var
bu
ne anlama
geliyor
buradaki işlemin
sonucu biter
bitmez
diğeri işini
görecek
buradaki işlemin
sonucu biter
bitmez
diğeri işini
görecek
ama
diğerini de
düşünün
arkadaşlar
diğeri de
burada
kod çalıştırıyor
sonra
bekliyor
ama
beklemekte
işi bitmiyor
ki
yazmıyorum
soyutlama
yapıyorum
ondan sonra
beklemeden
çıkınca
diğer
thread'in
oluşturduğu
sonucu
kullanıyor
sonra yine
bir takım
işlemler
yapıyor
belki sonra
yine
bekliyor
Mehmet Ali
anlaşıldı
değil mi
evet
tabii
arkadaşım çok
haklı
örnek sadece
böyle olunca
senkronla
asenkron
arasındaki
farkı da
göstermemiş
oluyoruz
Alihan
Bozkır
birbirini etkilemeyen
işlemler
eş zamanda
yapılsın
ve zaman
kazanılsın
diye
kesinlikle
hem onun için
hem de
şöyle
burada şimdi
zaten
iki farklı
thread çalıştırdığında
zaten bunlar
eş zamanlı
yapılıyor
ama buradaki
bütün mesele
iki ya da
daha fazla
thread arasında
birinin
oluşturduğu
sonuçtan
diğerinin
belirli bir noktada
faydalanmak
zorunda olması
mesela kafamızda
biraz daha canlı
bir örnek yapalım
şimdi biz
konsümer olan
thread'iz
kodu koşturduk
koşturduk
ama bu noktada
bizim
bir dosyadan
bir veriyi
okumamız
gerekiyor
ama o dosya henüz
oluşturulmamış
olabilir değil mi
o dosyanın
oluşturulduğundan
emin olarak
devam edeceğiz
eğer o dosya
oluşturulmadan
başka bir thread
o dosyayı
oluşturmadan
biz
işimizi yapmaya
kalkarsak
tanınsız
davranış
oluşacak
ama biz
sistemin
böyle çalıştığını
bildiğimiz için
condition
veriyi
bu üstünden
bekliyoruz
uyandığımız
anda
artık
o beklediğimiz
işin
tamamlandığını
öğreniyoruz
bir sorum daha
olacak hocam
red flag'in
her iki
thread'in
cash'inde
tutulmayacağı
garantileniyor
değil mi
kesinlikle
şimdi
cash'inde
tutulmaması
aslında
yani
ben ne demek
istediğinizi anlıyorum
ama
o tamamen
donanımsal bir şey
burada garanti edilen
şu
işte bunu da
dedim ya
bu konunun
en sonunda
göreceğiz
arkadaşlar
burada
garanti edilen
şu
buradaki
weight
fonksiyonundan
çıkıldığı zaman
bize
artık
diğer
thread'in
oluşturduğu
sonucun
visible
olduğu
garantisi
veriliyor
işte buradaki
ilişkiye
senkronize
olma ilişkisi
deniyor ki
bunu en
zor
anlayacağım
farklı farklı
araçlarla
mesela az önce
ben
condition variable
kullanmadım
yine bu garanti
vardı
condition variable
da böyle bir garanti
veriyor
ama bu garantiyi
veren
bazı başka
senaryolar
daha var
yani bütün
mesele
aslında burada
senkronizasyon
derken bütün
mesele
neyle ilgili
bir
thread
çalışıyor
ve
bir
durum değişikliğine
neden oluyor
bir durum değişikliğine
ama başka bir
thread
ya da
threadler
bu durum
değişikliğinin
yapıldığından
emin olarak
o durum
değişikliğinden
faydalanıyor
burada
bir
senkronizasyon
dil tarafından
garanti altında
olan bir
senkronizasyon
mekanizması
olmadan
bunu
sağlamak
mümkün değil
o zaman
tanımsız
davranış oluyor
ama bunu sağlamanın da
farklı farklı
araçları var
mesela bu konu
bittikten sonra
ya da bazı konular
son alt başlığımız
atomik değişkenler
olacak
bakın atomik değişkenleri
kullanıp
atomik değişkenler
vasıtasıyla da
böyle bir
senkronizasyon
sağlayabiliyoruz
evet
peki
o zaman
örneğimize
geri dönelim
arkadaşlar ve
önce
şu
iStack sınıfına
bakalım
arkadaşlar
tabii ki burada
sınıf
mükemmel bir sınıf
değil
minimal
konuyu anlatacak
ölçüde bir sınıf
ama bir şey
görmenizi istiyorum
şimdi
neler var
bir
iStack sınıfının
default
konstruktörü
herhangi bir koda
sahip değil
yani böyle
olmasıyla
ben bunu yazmayı
sevmiyorum
default edilmesi
arasında
bir fark yok
copy konstruktörü
ve copy assignment'ı
delete edilmiş
kopyalamaya karşı
kapatılmış
kapatılması da
son derece
doğal
çünkü zaten
mutex sınıfı
gerek mutex
sınıfı
gerek
condition
variable
sınıfı
zaten
hem kopyalamaya
hem taşımaya
kapalı
evet
tabi
biz copy art
bunlar
çok eskide kaldı
hepimiz biliyoruz
biz copy konstruktörü
ve
copy assignment'ı
delete ettiğimizde
zaten
move konstruktörü
ve move assignment
olmayacak
bakın şimdi
burada
aynı
condition variable'ı
kullanma garantisi var
çünkü
condition variable
bizim
iStack
sınıfımızın
non-static
veri elemanı
aynı şekilde
mutex de
arkadaşlar
bizim
non-static
data member'ımız
yalnız burada
bir şeye dikkat
bunu daha önce
birkaç
terste söylemiştim
şimdi dikkat ederseniz
ben size
sadece
push ve
pop fonksiyonlarını
gösteriyorum
mesela
burada
push fonksiyonu
ve pop fonksiyonu
dışında
diyelim ki
size isimli
bir fonksiyon
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
ve bu
size isimli
fonksiyon da
mutex'i
ve veya
condition variable'ı
kullansaydı
bu durumda
söyleyin
ne olması
gerekirdi
o dersi kim
hatırlıyor
bu durumda
bu
constüye fonksiyonu
olduğu için
mutex'in
fonksiyonu da
arkadaşlar
lock
unlock fonksiyonları da
gerek mutex'in
lock
unlock
gerek
condition variable'ın
weight fonksiyonları
bravo
alamboz
kırk
bunlar
arkadaşlar
sınıfın
non-constüye fonksiyonu
olduğu için
şu veri elemanlarının
mutable olması
gerekecekti
yani burada bir
mutable'ı
eksik görürseniz
örneğimizde
constüye fonksiyon
a
olmadığı için
ya da varsa da
bu mutex'i
ya da
condition variable'ı
kullanmadığı
içindir
şimdi
huş fonksiyonuna
bakalım ve
kritik birkaç
noktayı
tekrar görelim
bir
bir kere
condition variable
olsa da
olmasa da
shared
data'yı
korumak için
bir
ileti
bir mutex'i
kilitleyeceğim
ve burada
pekala
lock card'ı
kullanabilirdim
hiçbir engel
yok
ama
scope lock
effectively
lock card'ın
yerini tutar
ama daha fazlasını
yapar
birden fazla
mutex'i
kilitleyebilir
artık modern
c++'da
daha çok
scope lock'ın
kullanıldığını
göreceksiniz
demiştik
şimdi ne yapıyor
pushback fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
burada
derit arayısı
olma ihtimali yok
çünkü
kilit
bizde
evet
ondan sonra da
bir milisaniye
bekliyor
beklemesi nedeni
olayı daha iyi
gözlememizi
sağlamak
ve
notify one
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
böylece
bekleyen
thread'lerden
biri
notify one
ile
aynı condition
variable üstünde
bekleyen
thread'lerden
biri
arkadaşlar
notify one
ile uyandırılacak
bir şeye
dikkat
ve uyandırılacak
ama bu
birden fazla
thread'ı uyandırmak
isteseydi
tek bir çağrıyla
notify all
fonksiyonunu
çağıracaktı
ama
diğer taraftan
pop fonksiyonuna
bakalım
arkadaşlar
tabi
bizim standart
kütüphanemizin
stack sınıfı
hatırlayın
pop fonksiyonu
her zaman
void'tur
standart
konteynerların
exception
ending ile ilgili
nedenlerden dolayı
ama bizim
pop fonksiyonumuz
görüyorsunuz
int değer döndürüyor
yani
stackten
pop edilecek
edilen
değeri
döndürecek
burada
tekrar
söyleyelim
beklemeye
geçecek
thread'in
unique lock
kullanması
mecburi
önce
unique lock
lockable
nesnemizde
kilidi
aldık
kilitledik
mutex'i
sonra
weight fonksiyonunu
çağırdık
bu işte
birinci parametreye
unique lock
nesnesini
geçiyoruz
ikinci parametreye
arkadaşlar
ne geçiyoruz
söyleyin
predikatı
burada
geçmişte
öğrendiğimiz
bir konuyu da
gayet güzel
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
burada
lambda ifadesi
sınıfımızın
veri elemanını
kullanıyor
çünkü
aslında
bizim
stack olarak
kullandığımız
bir vektör
bu vektörü
kullanabilmesi için
capture etmesi
gerekiyor
bunu capture
etmek için de
dizi capture
etmemiz gerekiyor
değil mi
evet
dizi capture
ettik
ve predikat olarak
vekin empty
fonksiyonunu
çağırdık
yani boş
değilse
true değer
dönecek
artık lambda
ifadeleri vs.
bunların hepsi
oturduğunu
düşünüyoruz
burada
bu fonksiyonun
parametre değişkeni
olmadığı için
bu parantez
olmaya da
bilirdi
arkadaşlar
neden güldü
diyorsunuz
kayıttan insin
arkadaşlar
neden güldü
nezatiflerinden
biri değildir
Mehmet Ali Bey'in
sorusuna güldüm
soru kötü olduğu için
değil de soruşlarsın
baka şöyle demiş
hocam çok soru
soruyorum
hakkınızı helal edin
arkadaşlar
milyon tane
soru sorabilirsiniz
tabii ki
soru sormak
en doğal hakkınız
ve isteniyor zaten
lambda çağrıldığında
m ve k
erişiyoruz
bu spurious
wake up olduğunda
shared access'in
güvenli olduğu
garantisi
veriliyor mu
evet
onu söyledim
ama bir kez daha
söyleyeyim
kaçırmış olabilirsiniz
soru
bu fonksiyonun
bu fonksiyon
derken
lambda function'dan
bahsediyorum
bu fonksiyonun
arkadaşlar
yani
predikat olarak
kullanılan fonksiyonun
mutex
kilitliyken
çağrılmış
çağrılıyor
olma garantisi
var mı
kesinlikle
yani bu
arkadaşıma soru
son derece
önemli onu
söyledim ama
belki
yeterince
vurgulamamış
olabilirim
bu fonksiyon
kesinlikle
mutex
edinilmiş
yani kilitlenmiş
durumdayken
çağrılıyor
eğer böyle bir
garanti
olmasaydı
bizim
bu
sınıfımızın
veri elemanı
olan vektörü de
data race'e
karşı
korumamız
gerekirdi
yani
anlaşıldı mı
evet
şimdi
vektörün
back fonksiyonunu
biliyorsunuz
vektörün
back fonksiyonu
vektördeki
son öğeğe
erişiyor
dolayısıyla biz
vektörün
back fonksiyonunun
geri dönüşü
diye
asla referans
ama
intörden bir
değişkende
sakladık
sonra
halen kilit
altındayız
çünkü
uyanınca
kilit
bizde
popback fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
onu vektörden
çıkarttık ve
value
return
ettik
böylece
push fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
bir yandan
hop fonksiyonu
örneğin
farklı
threadler
tarafından
çalıştırılabilir
şimdi
izleyin
ben
bir de
ne kodu
yazmışım
biraz karmaşık
olabilir
bakın
görün
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi yavaş yavaş
gidelim
buradaki
iStack
global bir
değişken
global değişken
olması
burada
onun
paylaşımlı
kullanılacağı
vurgusu
için
constexperer
en değişkeni
arkadaşlar
yani bu
döngü
20 kez
dönsün
ama
istersen
burayı
50 yapıp
50 kez
dönmesini
sağlayabilirim
bu amaçla
yani kodda
değişikliği
birden fazla
yerde
yapmamak
şimdi bakın
producer
ve
consumer
upstream
sınıfı
türünden
bir referans
parametreye
sahip
bunun
tek nedeni
yani burası
burada karmaşıkla
önce bir devre dışı
bırakalım
tek nedeni şu
benim bunun
bu sistemin
doğru bir şekilde
çalıştığını
gösterebilmem
için
arkadaşlar
ekrana bir şeyler
yazdırmam
gerekiyor
ama bir
minisaniye
sürekli yazacak
bir şey takip edemeyeceğiz
bir daha scroll
olacak
muhtemelen
önce yazılanlara
da erişemeyeceğiz
ama bunları
dosyaya yazdırırsam
dosyada her şeyin
nasıl geliştiğini
görebiliriz
producer
en kez dönen bir döngüyle
bu arada aman dikkat
tabii ki producer
ve consumer
işte aslında
Mehmet Ali Bey'in
sorusunun da
bir yerde cevabı oluyor
bir önceki sorusunun
producer ve consumer
dikkat ederseniz
ayrı fonksiyonlar
ve ayrı
threadler tarafından
çalıştırılacaklar
producer'ın da
consumer'ın da
parametresi
offstream
ref
böylece
aynı dosyaya
bunların
ikisinin de
yazmasını
sağlayacağım
arkadaşlar
evet
bu arada
tabii bu
dosya üstünde
yazma işleminin
senkronize edilmesini
sağlayan
aslında buradaki
osing stream
sınıfı
c++20 ile gelen
daha önce biz hep
cout nesnesini
senkronize etmek için
kullanmıştık ama
şimdi bu da
bir o stream nesnesi
dosyaya
yazma işlemini
senkronize etmek için
kullanıyoruz
evet şimdi
producer'a bakalım
producer ne yapıyor
döngünler turunda
push fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
ve takip edebilmemiz
için
push fonksiyonuna
iki çarpı
i artı
bir değerin
yani
i sıfırken
bir tek sayıları
ekliyor değil mi
evet ve
her ekleme işleminden
sonra
dosyaya
hangi değerin
eklendiğini
yazıyor
consumer
bu da
ayrı bir
thread tarafından
çalıştırılacak
bu da
en kez dönen bir
döngü
bu da
arkadaşlar
pop fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
ama işte
az önce gördünüz
push fonksiyonu
ve pop fonksiyonu
senkronize edildi
condition variable
sayesinde
yani burada
örneğin
pop fonksiyonu
çağırıldığında
stack boş
ise
orada
bekleyecek
thread
değil mi
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
şimdi
şurası eksik
çıkmış
orayı
kopyalarken
tekrar buraya
gelelim
evet
önce
alt.txt
şu dosya
ben onu
hep açık
bulunduruyorum ki
görün
dosya oluşturulmadıysa
programı
sonlandırdım
tabi
fonksiyonun
parametresi
referans olduğu için
daha önce
öğrenmiştik
bu
çalıştırılacak
kolubula
threadler tarafından
çalıştırılacak
kolubula
bunu argüman olarak
geçerken
referans
semantiğine
geçebilmemiz için
reference wrapper
sınıf nesnemizi
kullanıyoruz
o da
işte burada
çağırdığımız
ref
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
evet
bakalım şimdi
bakın şimdi
bir push
bir pop
push
pop
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
bunlar
şimdi burada
bir değişiklik yapalım
mesela
ne yapalım
şurada
bekleme vardı
bir yerde
evet
bir milisaniye
bekliyordu
mesela
burada
5 milisaniye
beklesin
evet
görüyorsunuz
yine
herhangi bir şey
değişmedi
evet
bir ara verelim
saat
21.01
21.20
devam edeceğiz
Mehmet Ali Bey'in
sorusunun
üstüne
şöyle bir
cevap daha
verelim
tam olarak
arkada
hangi sırayla
neler oluyor
onları bir
payda
geçirmeye
çalışalım
şimdi
birkaç tane
başlık
dosyası
mutex
condition
variable
başka
ne
lazım
birkaç
iostream
hatta bir de
string
bu sefer
paylaşımla
değişkenimiz
string olsun
yine
ne diyelim
shared
variable
bir tane
mutex
stut
mtx
tane
condition
variable
stut
condition
variable
bir de
kendi bir
flag
değişken
pull
red flag
eşitler
false
şimdi bakın
her kodemede
kimin
beklediğini
kimin kilidi
aldığını
yazdıracağım
bu arada
using namespace
stut
literals
ya da belki sadece stut
chrono literals
bu da olabilir
burada da kullanabiliyorum
zaten inline namespace bunlar
evet
void
reader
ve
void
writer
şimdi
önce
reader'ı yazalım
mutex'i kilitleyeceğini bir bildirsin
reason
reader
is
locking
the mutex
burada uniclock'ı kullanacak
yine
stut
uniclock
ulak
mutex
ya da uzun haliyle
stut
mutex açılımı
çivarlık
buraya geldiğimizde
mutex'in kilitli olduğu
kesin değil mi
evet
onu bir yazdıralım
arkadaşlar
see out
reader
has
locked
the mutex
yani bu
statement
mutex
kilitleyken
gerçekleştiriliyor
şimdi
amaç ne
reader'ı
uyutmak
o zaman
şöyle diyelim
önce
uyumadan önce
reader
is
going
to
sleep
now
reader
uyusun
condition
variable
cv
weight
birinci
parametresine
ulak
ikinci
parametresine
predicate
read the flag
return
arkadaşlar programın akışı buraya gelmişse
bizim thread'imiz zaten uyanmış demektir
spurious wake up olsa da olmasa da artık uyandı
çünkü spurious wake up ise
arka plandaki döngü onu yine uyutuyor
yani burada artık verinin hazır olduğundan eminiz
işte senkronizasyon noktası burası
yine yazdıralım
reader
efendim ne diyelim
wakes up
ya da walk up
şimdarlık
şimdarlık şerit datayı
kullanabilir
neydi onun ismi
şerit data
see out
arkadaşlar programın akışı buraya geldiğinde
scope'un sonu olduğu için
mutex yine
unlock edilecek değil mi
ama
onu da yazdıralım
see out
reader
unlocks
the
mutex
evet buraya kadar bir hata olmadığından emin olalım
şimdi gelelim writer'a
not by one çağrısını
gilid altında yapmak istemiyorum
o yüzden burada bir nested scope oluşturdum
şimdi
writer
red
ya da writer
is
locking
the mutex
diyelim ki
scope lock
ya da
lock lock
lock
mutex
buradan kopya yapayım
writer has locked the mutex
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
şimdi burada
sözde
işi yapıyor
şimdi kritik yer burası
aslında burada çalışan bir kod var
veriyi hazırlayacak
ya da diğer thread'in
beklediği şeyi oluşturacak
ama biz tabi
burada bir kod
olmadığına göre
şöyle yazabiliriz
arkadaşlar
evet
daha şöyle bir şey de yazabilirim
neyse
stud
ne yapalım
his threads
wait for
sleep for
mesela
ne kadar beklesin?
100 mil saniye
yok
biraz daha beklesin
mesela
2 saniye beklesin
tamam
şimdi
datayı
değiştirecek
işi bitti
sözde
see out
writer
sets
ve
data
gerçekten de
edi değişkenimizin ismi
shared data
eşittir
necati
ergin
ayrak değişkenimizin ismi ne?
ready flag
rule
ve şimdi
programın akışı
buraya geldi
hatta şurada yazdıralım
see out
writer
is
sending
the
notification
ve burada
notify one
fonksiyonunu çağırdık
cv
notify one
şimdi
her iki
kolabalımızda
hazır
evet
şimdi main fonksiyonunda
bunları
koşturalım
arkadaşlar
önce
shared data
bir start
detayları
koşturmadan
bir değer
atayalım
not ready
shared data
is
şu anda
direktler daha koşmuyor
önce
writer'ı
çalıştırayım
tut
jdread
ya da
thread
e
writer
burada
bunun
daha önce çalışmaya
başladığını
başlamasını sağlayalım
ki
diğeri
arkadaşlar
notifikasyon gönderilmeden
bekleme durumuna geçmesin
öyle bir riske
almayalım
o yüzden
spot
this
thread
sleep
for
örneğin
milisaniye
bekletelim
ondan sonra
diğer
thread'i
koşturalım
e
reader
şuraya
dur
bakın
arka planda
neyleri
bulduğunu
bence
gayet güzel
göreceğiz
bakalım
şimdi
evet
şimdi bakın
yavaş yavaş
gidelim
shared data
is not ready
writer is
locking
the mutex
şuradaki
yazı çıktı
writer has
locked
the mutex
çünkü
lock
kartla
kilidi
mutex'i kilitledim
reader is
locking
the mutex
demek ki
bakın
burada
reader devreye
girdi
arkadaşlar
izleyin
reader is
locking
the mutex
writer
sets
the data
writer
is sending
the notification
reader has
locked
the mutex
reader is
going to
sleep
now
reader
uyandı
ve shared data
necati ergin
ve reader
yine kilidi
bıraktı
evet
şimdi burada
az önce
arkadaşıma
sorduğu
sorunun cevabını
da
tekrar
gösterelim
burada
writer
tarafına
bakarsak
bir
programın
akışı
bu noktaya
gelmişse
zaten
bu mutex
kilitli durumda
yani buradaki
kodlar
tamamı
mutex
kilit altındayken
kilitlenmişken
çalışıyor
bu bir
iki
burada
yine
ulak isimli
değişkenimiz
bir
lockable
olduğu için
skobunun
sonunda
destraktörü
çağrılıyor
arkadaşlar
destraktörü
mutex'in
kilidini
açıyor
iki
buradaki
predikat olan
callable
çağrıldığında
yine
mutex kilitli
işte bunu
kod doğrudan
göstermiyor
ama burada
wait fonksiyonunun
açılımı
aslında
şöyle
önce kilidi
edindi
arkadaşlar
önce kilidi
serbest bıraktı
kendisini
uyuttu
ondan sonra
uyandığı zaman
kilidi
tekrar aldı
predikatı
çağırdı
predikat false
dönerse
tekrar uyudu
sonra tekrar
kilidi
aldı
herhangi bir
noktada
kilit alındı
yani
mutex kilitlendi
ve
bizim
predikatımız
true değer döndürdü
o zaman
kilidi edinmiş
durumda
ve diğer
thread'in
işini
gerçekleştirdiğinden
emin bir şekilde
buradaki
kodu
çalıştırdı
reader fonksiyonu
önce çalışsa
deadlock olur
muydu
reader
thread'i önce
çalışsa
bu
notification'ı
kaçırabilirdi
ve
tabii ki
orada notification
kaçtığı için
sürekli
bekleme
durumunda
kalabilirdi
yani sürekli
bloke
olabilirdi
bir
arkadaşımın
daha
sorusu
vardı
mutexler
multi
thread
işlemlerde
paralelizmi
bozmuyor mu
sonuçta
beklemek
zorunda
kalıyor
diğer
thread
arkadaşlar
zaten
bakınız
beklemek
dışında
bir ihtimal
daha var
ama
burası
artık
programlamanın
ne diyelim
en fazla
uzmanlık
gerektiren
ve çok
çok zor
bir alanı
ona
herhangi bir
şekilde
kilitleme
olmadan
bir programın
tamamen
hiçbir
thread'in
beklemesini
sağlamadan
bir kilit
mekanizması
olmadan
arkadaşlar
programı
yazmak da
mümkün
ama orası
ayrı bir
uzmanlık
alanı
belki
bu konunun
sonunda
ondan da
bir örnek
verebiliriz
ama o
artık ben
hazır
yazılmış
bir
od üstünden
gösterebilirim
yani
teknik olarak
teorik olarak
hiçbir
mutex
kullanılmadan
fiilen
bir mutex
kilitleme
olmadan da
herhangi bir
şekilde
senkronizasyon
sağlanabilir
ve
bitredin
hiçbir zaman
bloke
edilmemesini
sağlayabilir miyiz
işte o tür
programlamaya
arkadaşlar
block free
programming
deniyor
adı üstünde
kilit olmadan
programlama
hocam
debug modda
satırları
seçerek
kodun
o andaki
davranışını
step by step
kontrol edebiliyorduk
bunu
Visual Studio'da
multi thread
jeren kodlar
için yapabiliyor muyuz
arkadaşlar
debuggerların
bu
multi thread
programlar
için
verdikleri
destek
birbirinden
farklı
yine
en fazla
desteği
bu
GDP
yani
gcc'deki
debugger
veriyor
onu
kendisine
sormalısınız
yani
ne kadar
destek verdiği
tamamen
debuggerdan
debuggera
değişebiliyor
evet
burada
Visual Studio
tarafında
çok fazla
bir destek
yok
yani
istediğiniz
biçimde
onu birebir
takip edebileceğiniz
bir destek
mekanizması
yok
zaten
multi thread
programlarda
en zorunlan
olaylardan
biri de
debug etme
zorluğu
çünkü
mesela
bazen
böyle
senaryolar
var ki
arkadaşlar
11 milyonda
bir ihtimalle
mesela
deadlock
oluşması
söz konusu
o yüzden
test etmek
falan da
çok zor
evet
peki
şimdi
birkaç örnek
daha görelim
ve doğrudan
artık şu
promise ve
future
sınıflarına
bakalım
arkadaşlar
şimdi bakın
bu sefer
biraz daha
karmaşık bir örnek
ama
gerçeğe daha
yakın bir örnek
o yüzden
biraz
dikkatli
izlememiz gerekiyor
çok fazla
detay var
izleyin
şimdi bakın
aynı işi
bir
condition
variable
kullanmadan
iki
condition
variable
kullanarak
gerçekleştireceğiz
ama örneğin
yapışından
sonuna
çok yavaş
gidersek
bütün
geriye kalan
vaktimizi
harcamış
oluruz
o yüzden
biraz daha
arkadaşlar
hızlı gitmem
gerekiyor
native
fonksiyonları
windbg ile
debug edebiliriz
peki
şimdi bakın
burada şöyle
bir senaryo var
ismi
receive data
isimli
bir fonksiyon
var
bu fonksiyon
sözde
datayı
sürekli
alacak
ama
datayı
alması için
arkadaşlar
datanın hazır
olması gerekiyor
datayı
elde ettikten
sonra
datayı
yazdıracak
ve
bir bayrak
değişkeni de
true
değerine
getiriyor
aslında örneğin
üstünden
geçsek mi
geçmesek mi
ben de
şüphede kaldım
çünkü bayağı
bir zamanımızı
alacak
isterseniz
önce sizin
incelemenize
bırakalım
ondan sonra
belki bir sonraki
derste
sizle
kodu inceledikten
sonra üstünden
beraber geçelim
çünkü
bayağı bir
zamanımız
alacak
ama
şurada
yavaş yavaş
bir ilerlemeye
çalışalım
arkadaşlar
dikkat ederseniz
üç tane
ayrı
thread
oluşturuyorum
biri
aslında
datayı
alan
thread
buna
h underscore
fetch
ismini
verdim
fakat bir
tanesi de
sözde
hani bu
bu
uygulamalarında
olur ya
progress bar
hani veriyi
alırken
verinin
ne kadar
alındığını
gösteren
progress bar
o ayrı bir
thread
böylece bir yandan
veriyi alacağız
ama bir başka
thread de
progress bar'ı
sürekli
basacak
yani
hani böyle
gidiyor ya
arkadaşlar
veri alındıkça
şurada
şöyle gösterelim
çizgi çizgi çizgi çizgi
çizgi artıyor
bu da onun karşılığı
olsun
bir de
veri alındıktan
sonra
o alınan
veriyi
bekleyecek
ancak bütün
veri alındıktan
sonra o veriyi
proses edecek
ayrı bir
thread var
yani
veri alınırken
ve progress bar
çalışırken
bunlar
eş zamanlı olarak
koyacak
arkadaşlar
eş zamanlı olarak
çalışacak
ama
proses
datanın
çalışması için
bu
ismi
fetch olan
receive
datanın
datayı
alıp
hazırlaması
gerekecek
ama şimdi
bakın
burada
ilkinde
şunu göstermeye
çalışıyorum
aslında pekala
condition variable
olmadan da
bunu yapabiliriz
ama
tabi
burada
condition variable
kullanmakla
kullanmamak
arasındaki
farkı baştan
konuştuk
işlemci zamanının
hoş harcanması
ya da harcanmaması
şimdi
bakınız
burada
iki tane
ayrı
boolean
değişken var
biri
o
progress bar için
progress flag
değişkeni
diğeri de
o verinin
alınıp
alınma
sürecinin
bittiğini
ne diyelim
bir şekilde
evet
maalesef
bir kopma oldu
nerede
tam koptuğunu
herhalde bir ara
elektrik mi kesildi
internet bağlantısı
kesildi
o yüzden
tam en son olarak
ne duyduğunuzu da
bilmiyorum ama
kaldığım yerden
ben devam edeyim
bir arkadaşım
yazmış
hocam tam
başlatmıştınız
anlatmaya
tamam
arkadaşlar
ne kadar
duyulduğunu
bilmediğim için
şimdi tekrar
buradan devam
edeceğim
burada
sözde
bir yandan
veri alınıyor
progress bar
çalıştırılıyor
ama
alınan veri
bittiğinde
progress bar da
bu durumda
yüzde yüz olacak
başka bir
thread de
o veriyi
kullanacak
ama bakın
bu
th
process
isimli
thread değişkeninin
kontrol ettiği
thread'in
işini görmesi için
verinin
tamamının
alınmış olması
gerekiyor
ama
şu ikisi
eş zamanlı
olarak yürüyecek
yani bir yandan
data alınacak
data alındıkça
progress bar
ilerleyecek
ama bu
datanın alınması
bittikten sonra da
process data
devreye girecek
ve
hazırlanmış
alınmış
artık nereden
alınıyorsa
networkten
şuradan buradan
o datayı
kullanacak
şimdi
değişkenlerimize
bakalım
burada
condition
variable
kullanmıyoruz
ama
aynı örneği
bundan sonra
biraz değiştireceğiz
condition
variable
kullanarak
gerçekleştireceğiz
bu bizim
sürekli
aldığımız
data
ama burada
şöyle bir
espri
söz konusu
olacak
bu
str
data
isimli
değişken
veri alındıkça
yavaş yavaş
alınıyor ya
veri
çalıştıkça
daha fazla
veri geliyor
ben
onu göstermek
için
bu str
data
isimli
değişkeni
sürekli
update
edeceğim
etmek de
aslında
görüyorsunuz
burada
string
sınıfının
artı eşit
fonksiyonuyla
yazının
sonuna
ekleme
yapacağım
önce
şu
receive
data'yı
bir görmenizi
istiyorum
10 kez
dönen bir
döngü
yani
sözde
datayı
10 aşamada
alacağız
her aşamada
progress
barı da
ilerleteceğiz
döngüye
girişte
şu yazı
çıkacak
receiver
threat
waiting
for
data
yani
bir yerden
data
gelecek
efendim
bir saniye
bekletiyorum
hani burada
data'nın alınması için
bir vakit geçiyor
onu göstermek için
ve burada
dikkat
laggard'la
bilidi edindim
şuradaki
yalnız burada bir şeye
dikkat edin
iki ayrı
mutex var
neden
mutexlerden biri
şu data
nesnesi
üstündeki
erişimi
senkronize
etmek için
arkadaşlar
ama diğer
mutex'te
şu
is completed
değişkenini
senkronize
etmek için
çünkü
diğer
thread'in
veri hazır
ben işimi
yapmaya
başlayabilirim
o bilgiyi
almak için
o polling
yapacak
ve
is completed'i
gözleyecek
şimdi sanırım
biraz daha
yanlışlıyor
evet
laggard'la
kilidi edindim
çok aşikar olan
yerlerin üstünden
geçmeyeceğim
sözde datayı
aldık
datayı
almamız da
şu demek
blok blok
geliyor
data
önce blok
yazısı
çıkacak
efendim
i artı
bir
arkadaşlar
bunu yazıya
dönüştürüyorum
i sıfırken
bir olacak
dolayısıyla
döngünün
her turunda
şöyle olacak
blok
bir
artı
blok
iki
artı
blok
üç
artı
blok
dört
bu döngü
bittiğinde
bizim
aslında
verimiz
alınmış
olacak
ve verinin
son hali
blok
bir
artı
blok
iki
artı
nereye
kadar
blok
ona
kadar
buraya şöyle
bir kod daha
koydum
eğer
i9
değilse
araya
bir de
çizgi
koysun
ki
onu
daha kolay
gözleyelim
yani
her aşamada
verinin
bir kısmı
geliyor
ve döngünün
her turunda
bu
thread
çalışırken
her
bloku
aldıktan
sonra
ne
kadarlık
verinin
alınan
veriyi
yazdırıyor
dolayısıyla
döngünün
ilk turunda
burada ne
yazacak
str data
arkadaşlar
blok
sonra
tire
blok
sonra
tire
blok
böyle
geçiyor
ama
şeye
bakın
döngünün
her turunda
progress
flag'i
true
değerine
çekiyor
progress
flag
bizim
buradaki
diğer
threadle
haberleşmemizi
sağlayacak
değişken
tekrar
burada
önemli
şunu
söyleyelim
eğer
biz burada
aynı
mutex'i
kullanarak
aynı
değişkeni
diğer
thread
tarafından
gözlenmesini
sağlamasaydık
yani
burada
bu
mutex
vasıtasıyla
bir
senkronizasyon
ilişkisi
kurulmasaydı
diğerinin
bu
flag'i
true
ya da
false
olarak
gözlemesinin
hiçbir anlam
ifade etmeyecekti
arada
gerçek bir
senkronizasyon
oluşmayacaktı
bakın
döngünün
tamamlanmasından
sonra
arkadaşlar
şunu
ne diyelim
evet
receive
şurayı da
değiştirelim
str
data
has ended
yani
verinin alınmasının
bittiğini
gösterdik
bakın
tekrar bir
laggard nesnesi
kullandım
bu sefer de
şu
is completed
true
hale getirdim
burada
yine
kilit altında
bu işlem
yapıldı
burada
şu döngünün
her turunda
şuradaki
işlemlerde
kilit altında
yapıldı
ama şimdi
bakın
condition
variable
kullanmadan
hem kod
daha karmaşık
hale geldiğini
göreceksiniz
kodun
daha karmaşık
hale gelmesi
bir yana
aynı zamanda
bir de
sürekli
polling yaparak
işlemci zamanını
boşa harcamış
olacağım
arkadaşlar
burada bir değişken
var
otomatik ömürlü
değişken
dolayısıyla
bunu
koruman
gerekmiyor
while döngüsü
bu döngüden
ne zaman
çıkacak
sonsuz döngü
olduğu için
break statement
bakın
bu noktada
çıkacak
şimdi bakalım
döngünler
durumda
progress
respire
thread
waiting
for data
burada
datanın
alınmasına
bekleyecek
her data
her alındığında
progress
bar da
o da
bir şey
yazacak
arkadaşlar
verinin ne kadar
alındığını
dolayısıyla
kilidi ediniyor
şimdi burada
polling yapıyor
bakın
progress flag
false olduğu
sürece
kilidi
daha önceki örnekte
ilk
bugünkü dersin
başında
gördüğümüz örnekte
olduğu gibi
kilidi açıyor ki
diğeri çalışsın
10 milisaniye
bekliyor
tekrar kilidi
mütex
kilitliyor
ne zaman
burada aynı
mütex üstünden
senkronizasyon
sağlandığı için
programın akışı
buraya geldiğinde
bu threadte
artık diğer
threadin
arkadaşlar
bir veri
aldığını
biliyoruz
önce
len değişkeninde
stl
data'nın
size'ını
yani kaç
karakter olduğu
bilgisini alıyorum
size de
göstermek için
progress flag'ı
false değerine
çekiyorum
burası çok önemli
progress flag
şu anda
false değerde
arkadaşlar
ve bir şeye
daha dikkat
burada
bu döngüden
çıktığı zaman
arkadaşlar
progress flag
diyelim ki
draw hale
geldi
ama halen kilit
bizde
değil mi
şu anda bu işlemler
yine
kilit altında
yapılıyor
size'ı elde ettim
progress flag'i
false hale getirdim
progress flag
false oldu
ve tekrar
kilidi
açtım
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
bu noktada
bu kadar
datanın
alındığını gösteren
bir yazı
yazdırdım
fakat şimdi
buraya dikkat
tekrar
bu sefer
diğer mutex'i
kullanarak
kilitledim
ve
is completed
eğer true
değerde ise
işimin
bittiğini
anladım
ve döngüden
çıktım
döngüden çıkmam
demekte
zaten
bu
kolumun
çalışması
sonlandı
burada dikkat ederseniz
sonlanıp
sonlanmadığını
döngünün
her turunda
diğer bayrak
değişkenin
is completed'in
true hale
gelip gelmediğini
sınayarak
karar veriyorum
process data'ya
bakalım
şimdi
process data'nın
işini yapması için
data'nın hazır
olması gerekiyor
olması için
arkadaşlar
bu kilide edindi
bakın burada da
polling yapacağız
evet
mtx
completed
yani
burada
en son
veri bittiğinde
bu true
hale gelecekti
evet
ve
şuradayız
yine
polling yapıyor
is completed
false olduğu sürece
kilidi açtı
bekledi
tekrar kilitledi
buradan çıktığında
artık
verinin hazır olduğu
kesin
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağırdık
ve
tekrar bu sefer
arkadaşlar
data'yı koruyan
mutex'i kilitledik
ve
bunu
ekrana
yazdırdık
evet
biraz karmaşık gibi
ama aslında
çok da fazla
karmaşık değil
iki thread
birlikte çalıştı
üçüncü thread'te
data hazır olduğunda
o datayı
kullanarak
sözde
işini gördü
evet
bakın şimdi
bitsin
evet
bakın şimdi
baştan sona
bakalım
receiver thread
waiting for data
progress part
thread waiting
for data
processing
thread waiting
for data
ilk data geldi
blok 1
sonra
7 byte
aldı
bunlar yazdırılıyor
arkadaşlar
sonra
data blok 1
blok 2
14 byte oldu
sürekli geldi
geldi geldi
en son
arkadaşlar
blok 10
da alındı
şuraya bakın
receive
str data
zende
datanın alınması
bitti
receive processing
the data
received
70 byte
alınmış
progress part
thread
bitmiş
ve artık
process
veriyi
kullanan
buradaki ismi
neydi
process data
fonksiyonu
verinin hazır
olduğunu bilip
işini
görmüş
şimdi ama
aynı kodu
bakın
iki ayrı yerde
polling yaptık
şimdi
tamamen kodu
değiştireceğiz
ve condition
variable
kullanacağız
bir bitireyim
burayı
rastor
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
yavaş yavaş
gidelim
burada
progress flag
yine var
is completed
mutexlerimiz
yine var
ama bakın
iki tane
condition variable
değişkenimiz var
lardan bir tanesi
o veri aldıkça
progress bar'ın
uyandıracak
diğeri de
arkadaşlar
bu
cv completed
de
neyi
uyandırmak için
veri hazır olana kadar
o veriyi
proses edecek
thread uyuyacak
ama bizim
condition variable
cv completed
onu uyandıracak
kodun sadece
değişen kısmını
göstermek istiyorum
arkadaşlar
burada
izleyin
yine veriyi
alan kısım
çalıştı
ve
şurada
kilitledi
ve bakın
bu noktada
kilidi açtık
sonra
notify all
fonksiyonunu
çağırdı
böylece
bekleyen
bütün
threadleri
döngünün
her turunda
notification'ı
gönderdi
artık
polling
yapmıyoruz
ve burada
işte
datanın
alındığını
tamamlandığını
gösteren
yazıyı
yazdırdı
ve burada
yine
lag kartla
bu sefer
diğer mutex'i
kilitledi
emran çelik
burada neden
unique lag var
son derece
basit
unique lag
olmak zorunda
değil
ama burada
unique lag
kullanmamın
nedeni
burada
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor olmam
takip edebiliyor muyuz
neden derseniz
burada
notify
fonksiyonunu
kilit açıkken
çağırmak
istediğim için
eğer burada
unique lag
kullanmasaydım
ki
kullanmayabilirdim
isterseniz
değiştireyim
o zaman
bakın
sizin için
değiştireceğim
unique lag
yerine
lag kart
kullanayım
çünkü
burası
bekleyen
thread
ama
lag kart
kullandığım zaman
burada
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağıramam
o zaman da
şöyle yapabilirim
şuraya
bir blok daha
oluştururdum
bravo ayağım
şöyle yazalım
ve burada
notify all
fonksiyonunu
bu şekilde
çağırabilirim
yanlış anlaşılmasın
notify all
burada da
çağırsan
herhangi bir şekilde
programın
doğruluğu
açısından
bir problem
olmayacaktı
ama bir
verim kaybı
olacağı
söyleniyor
anlaşıldı mı
evet
şimdi buraya
gelelim
burada da
yine
bu sefer
diğer mutex'i
lag kartla
edindim
gördüğünüz gibi
burada
lag kartı
kullanıyorum
çünkü
zaten
bir
lag ya da
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağırmayacağım
is completed
bayrak değişkenliği
turuya çektim
ve tekrar
notification
gönderdim
bakın
burada
döngünün
her turunda
notify fonksiyonunu
çağırdığım zaman
bu notify one
da olabilirdi
ayrıca bu örnekte
notify fonksiyonunu
her çağırdığımda
burada
o
progress barı
yürüten
thread
uyanacak
ama
thread'in
akışı
bu noktaya
geldiğinde
buradaki
notify'da
şu
arkadaşlar
proses
datayı
uyandıracak
şimdi
diğerlerine
bakalım
progress bar
burada
yeni
unique lock
burada
kullanmak mecburi
emiram
yani
diğerinde
mecburi
değil tabi
ama burada
kesinlikle
mecburi
çünkü
wait fonksiyonu
lock ve
unlock fonksiyonlarını
çağırıyor
unique lock
ile kilidi
edindim
ve işte
daha önceki örneklerde
olduğu gibi
predikat olarak
progress flag'ı
return eden
bir
lambda
ifadesi
kullandım
sonra
progress flag'ı
tekrar
false haline
getirdim
kilidi
açtım
ve ondan sonra
şu yazıyı
yazdırdım
fakat
bu noktaya
geldiğinde
arkadaşlar
tekrar
mutex'i
edindim
çünkü
neden
bitip
bitmediğini
buradan
yine
takip ediyorum
bu arada
neden
notify
olun da
kullanıldığını
takip edebiliyorsunuz
değil mi
demin onu
gözden kaçırmıştım
iki tane
ayrı thread
burada
uyanacak
mutex
completed
bayrağını
gözlemek için
burada
arkadaşlar
henüz göstermedim
şimdi
condition variable'ın
üç tane
fonksiyonu var
bir tanesi
wait
wait for
diğeri
wait until
burada
çağırdığım
fonksiyon
wait for
yine
boolean
değer döndürüyor
fakat
diğerinden
farkı
bu kadar
süre
arkadaşlar
bekliyor
yani bu kadar
süre içinde
uyandı
o zaman
true değer
döndürdü
uyanamadıysa
o zaman
arkadaşlar
false değer
döndürdü
dolayısıyla
döngünün her
turunda
şuradaki
if
de
10 milisaniye
bekleyecek
ve
arkadaşlar
uyanıp
uyanmadığına
bakacak
uyandıysa
bu döngüden
çıkacak
böylece
bütün
datayı
aldığını
aslında
döngünün
herhangi bir
turunda
şuradan
anlayacak
bir şekilde
anlaması
lazım
değil mi
burada
dikkat ederseniz
wait for
fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
wait
wait for
ve wait
until
olmak üzere
3 tane
wait fonksiyonu
var
geldik
process
data'ya
burada
yine
bakın
şu noktada
unique lock
kilidi
aldım
mutex'i kilitledim
yine
cv
completed
yani
şu
bayrağı
kontrol eden
diğer
condition
variable'ın
wait fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
ve
wait fonksiyonu
geri döndükten
sonra
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
burada
bu sefer
paylaşımda
veriye erişmek
için
tekrar
lock
kartla
mtx
data'yı
kullanarak
şu
değişkenin
şu değişkeni
koruyarak
data race
olmadan
burada
ismine
stl
data'yı
kullanmak
için
tekrar
mutex'i
kilitledim
ve
elde edilen
yazıyı
yazdırdım
ben de
bunları
gibi geçtiğim için
bir hata
olmadığından
eminim
ama siz
mutlaka
bu
gitaptan
benim paylaştığım
repodan
bunları bir üstünden
geçip
tekrar
yavaş yavaş
sorgulamanızda
fayda var
çünkü bir bakışta
hemen böyle
anlaşılacak
basitlikte değil
evet
arkadaşlar
notify ile
notify all
arasında
notify one ile
notify all
arasındaki
fark
notify one'ın
tek bir
trade uyandırması
notify all'un ise
bekleyen
bütün
trade'leri
uyandırması
şimdi
notify one'ı
göstermek için
şöyle bir örnek
yazdım
izleyin
bakın
burada
önce
main'e
bakalım
producer
consumer
iki tane
thread
biri
producer'ı
çalıştıracak
diğeri
consumer'ı
çalıştıracak
pardon
bu şunu
göstermek için
özür dilerim
bu örnek
notify all'u
göstermek için
değil
karşılıklı
aynı
condition
variable'ı
kullanarak
birbiri
arasındaki
haberleşmeye
göstermek için
arkadaşlar
bakın
dikkat ederseniz
bir tane
mutex var
boolean
değişkenimiz
var
bu da
sözde bizim
hazırlanacak
verimiz
bu da
condition
variable
değişkenimiz
şimdi
producer'da
10 kez
dönen bir
döngü var
consumer'da
da 10 kez
dönen bir
döngü var
producer
veri
üretecek
arkadaşlar
buraya dikkat
diğeri de
o veriyi
alacak
ama bir şeye
dikkat edin
veriyi
aldıktan
sonra
bu sefer de
bu veriyi
aldım
diye
diğerine
notification
gönderiyor
bir bakalım
şimdi
döngünün
her turunda
unique lock
ile kilit
dedik
mutex'e
datayı
hazırladık
data ready
değişkenini
true
değere
çektik
notify one
fonksiyonunu
çağırdık
böylece
diğer
thread'e
notification
gönderdik
sonra
arkadaşlar
uykuya
daldık
ama bakın
aynı değişkeni
kullanıyorum
şurada
gdata ready
var ya
burada
dikkat ederseniz
uyanması
için
gdata ready
false
olması
gerekiyor
ama
diğerinde
tam tersi
gdata ready
bayrak
değişkeninin
true
olması
gerekiyor
evrançelik
atomik
bul
görecek
miyiz
göreceğiz
zaten
3 dersimiz
kaldı
son dersimiz
atomiklerle
ilgili
olacak
arada da
iki konu
başlığımız
daha var
yani
iki tane
ana
birerli bir yerde
kesmek
zorundayız
sürek
biri
işte bu
future promise
sınıfı
birazdan
ona giriş yapacağım
zaten
future ve promise
sınıfları
sonra
async
fonksiyonu
ondan sonra da
atomik işlemler
en sonunda
konumuz
ha bu arada
package task
sınıfı var
onu da göreceğiz
package task
nasıl çalışıyor
ne işe yarıyor
ondan sonra da
atomiklere
ilerleyeceğiz
evet
şimdi burada
motioner tarafı da
yine döngünler
tırında
kilidi aldı
uyandırılmaya
kadar bekledi
uyanınca
kilit altında
gdata'yı
yazdırdı
ama sonra
bayrağı tekrar
falsa çekti
ve diğerini
notify etti
yani bu durumda
ne olacak
burası
veri hazırlayacak
öbürü
veriyi kullanacak
kullandım
diyecek
buna haber verecek
bu tekrar
veriyi hazırlayacak
yani
bu kullanına
kadar
hazırlayana
kadar da
diğer
trade
bekliyor
öyle bir
modeli göstermek
için
evet
dikkat ederseniz
herhangi bir
şekilde
takılmadı
veriler
alındı
verildi
arkadaşlar
şimdi tabi
daha bir saat
iki saat
condition variable
üstünde
konuşabiliriz
ama
belirli bir yerde
kesmemiz gerekiyor
ben şimdi
bu
concurrency ile
ilgili konularda
bitireceğim
az kaldı
her bir konu
başlığı için
çok sayıda
örnek hazırlıyorum
repoya
bakabilirsiniz
bir hata görürseniz
hatayı da düzeltmem için
bana bir bildirimde
bulunun lütfen
bir de her konuyla
ilgili de
o konuyu
anlatan
böyle çok uzun
olmasa da
notlar var
hatta
bir göstereyim
neden bahsettiğimi
biraz bekleteceğim
evet
yani
bununla birlikte
takip ederseniz
ancak anlam kazanacak
çünkü
özellikle
daha karmaşık
örnekler söz
konusu olduğunda
onu bu şekilde
hemen hızlı
üstünden
geçtiğimizde
çok fazla
fayda sağlamayacak
burada dikkat ederseniz
concurrency
reposunun altında
birden fazla
alt repo var
alt direktörü var
mesela
async
henüz görmedik
burada
atomiklerle ilgili
kodlar
örnekler
burada
condition variable
future
ve promise
burada
latch
burada olacak
memory model
ne demek
ne işe yarıyor
onunla ilgili
örnekler
burada
mutex de
ve lock'larla
ilgili
lockable'larla
ilgili kodlar
burada
once flag
bunun dışında
kalan
başka örnekleri
buraya attım
package test
henüz
görmedik
arkadaşlar
işte
paralel
programlamayla
ilgili
vesaire
semaforla
ve semaforla ilgili
thread'le ilgili
kodlar
kodlarda
yine burada
alt direktörler var
ama yakın zamanda
bunu tamamen
bitireceğim
ama burada
bir şey daha
göstermek istiyorum
şuraya da bir
notlar dosyası
ekledim
burada da
konularla ilgili
o konuları
anlatan
çok ayrıntılı
olmasa da
temel konulara
değinen
notlar var
mesela mutex'i
açtım
mutex'de
scaplaka açtım
bunun ne olduğunu
kısaca anlatıyor
ya da
time mutex'i açtım
time mutex nedir
bunu da bitirmek
üzereyim
hepsini tamamlamadım
mesela
unique lock
unique lock'la
ilgili
temel bilgiler
alian bosker
hocam
thread pool diye
bir ideomatik
yapı görmüştüm
aslında onu da
anlatıyorum
ileri c++
kursunda
arkadaşlar
sadece burada
parçurda
diğer birçok
programlama
dilinde
diğer birçok
programlama dilinin
standart kütüphanesine
thread pool da
standart kütüphanenin
bir öğesi
ama maalesef
bizde
thread pool
yani Türkçesiyle
thread havusu
standart kütüphanenin
bir bileşeni değil
yani ya kendiniz
oluşturacaksınız
ya da
hazır bir kütüphane
kullanacaksınız
şimdi thread pool'un
ne olduğunu
ne işe yaradığını
bir başka
derste yine
anlatacağım
ama kısaca şöyle
şimdi
threadleri
oluşturmanın
belirli bir
maliyeti var
daha önce konuşmuştuk
yani işletim sistemi
düzeyinde
sizin bir thread
oluşturmanız için
bazı işlemlerin
yapılması gerekiyor
bu
birçok
noktada
önemli
çünkü mesela
diyelim ki
bir algoritmayı
o konuya da
geleceğiz
paralel çalıştırmak
istiyorsunuz
paralel çalıştırıp
4 tane
thread'e
8 tane
böleyim
her thread
işin bir kısmını
yapsın
thread'lerin kullanılmasındaki
temel fikirlerden biri bu
yani işi daha önce
bitirmek
yani işin bir kısmı
şimdi thread'leri birden
farklı şekilde
kullanabiliyoruz
değil mi
buraya da biraz
değinelim
bir tanesi
mesela farklı
thread'ler
arkadaşlar
işin
farklı kısımlarını
yapıyor
ama bir de
farklı thread'ler
aynı data
üstünde
aynı işlemi yapıyor ki
daha hızlı
tamamlansın
diye
bu thread'leri
oluşturmanın da
bir maliyeti var
yani örneğin
bir algoritmayı
ben paralel
çalıştıracağım
diye
4 tane
8 tane
16 tane
thread oluşturursanız
o
senkron çalıştırdım
daha hızlı
bitti
böyle bir şey
diyemeyiz
duruma göre
değişir
çünkü
evet
birden fazla
thread
koşarak
işin belirli
kısımlarını
aynı zamanda
yapıyor
ama diğer taraftan
bir de
nasıl bir
overet geliyor
bu thread'lerin
oluşturulma
maliyeti
o da zaman
alıyor
dolayısıyla
orada
mutlaka bir
profiling
yapmak gerekiyor
yani thread'lere
bölmekle
bir fayda
sağlıyor muyum
yoksa
thread'i
oluşturmanın
maliyeti
onu bastırıyor mu
onu mutlaka
test etmem
gerekiyor
thread pool'da da
ne oluyor
sürekli thread
yaratmak yerine
thread'leri
baştan yaratıyoruz
thread'lerin bir
havuzunu
oluşturuyoruz
ve
thread'leri artık
tekrar tekrar
çalıştırma
maliyetinden
kurtuluyoruz
oluşmuş olan
thread'lere
bir kuyruk
sistemini
kullanarak
sürekli
testleri
görevleri
assign ediyoruz
burada
genel mantık
ne
thread'lerin
arkadaşlar
boş durmamasını
sağlamak
bir
iki
thread oluşturma
maliyetini
her defasında
yeni thread
oluşturma
maliyetinden
kaçırmak
tipik onun içinde
şöyle bir
analoji var
değil mi
mesela şirket
arabaları var
şirketin
sekiz tane
arabası var
kimin işi olursa
gidiyor
otoparka
şirketin
otoparkına
boşta olan
arabayı
alıyor
oysa
bu arabalar
hazır olmasa
o arabaları
edinmek için
her defasında
örneğin
ne diyelim
buna
analoji ne olabilir
ihtiyaç olduğunda
araba kiralansa
her defasında
o maliyet olacak
ama
arabalar
hazır bekliyor
kimin ihtiyacı
olursa
arabayı
kullanıyor
geri koyuyor
ama ondan sonra
aynı arabayı
tekrar bir başkası
kullanabiliyor
thread pool'un
genel mantığı
bu
aslında onunla
ilgili de
bir örnek yaparsak
bu 3 ders bitmeden
iyi olacak
ama bir de
zaman sınırımız var
o yüzden
birçok konuyu da
burada anlatamadım
ileri
C++
kursunda
anlatıyorum
semafor
görece çok daha
basit
arkadaşlar
onu belki
burada
yine o 3 ders içinde
görebiliriz
peki
şimdi
gelelim
future
ve promise
sınıflarına
arkadaşlar
bu
future
ve promise
sınıfları
aslında yine
bir thread'in
oluşturduğu
değeri
bir başka
thread'e
iletmenin
yani böyle bir
senkronizasyon
oluşturmanın
bir başka yolu
burada
yalnız
diğerinden farkı
örneğin
condition variable'dan
farkı
bir kere
kullanılacak
bir kanal
oluşturması
yani
örneğin
siz bir fonksiyonu
bir thread'le
çalıştırıp
o fonksiyondan
alınacak
geri dönüş
değerini de
başka bir
thread'e
iletmek
istiyorsunuz
bunun için
stud future
ve stud promise
sınıflarını
kullanabiliyorsunuz
burada
future ve promise
sınıfları
türünden
nesneleri
kullanarak
bu
iletişim
sağlanıyor
ama
şöyle bir
faydası var
diğer
thread'in
koşturduğu
colobal'ın
geri dönüş
değerini de
bu yolla
almanız
mümkün
aynı zamanda
o
thread'in
çalıştırdığı
fonksiyon
bir exception
gönderirse
yine bu
oluşturulan
shared state
üstünden
yine
exception'ı
elde etmeniz
mümkün
şimdi
aslında
normalde
önce
async
fonksiyonu
anlatılıyor
ondan sonra
benim gördüğüm
geneleyinim
future ve promise
sınıfları
anlatılıyor
ama ben
tam tersinin
daha uygun olduğunu
düşünüyorum
niçin
çünkü önce
future ve promise
sınıfları
nedir
nasıl kullanılıyor
ne işe yarıyor
bunların üye fonksiyonları
nelerdir
bunları anlarsak
async fonksiyonu
aslında geri planda
yine arkadaşlar
promise sınıfını
kullanarak
bize promise sınıfı
türünden
nesneden elde edilen
future nesnesini
döndürüyor
gerek package task
gerek
async fonksiyonu
geri planda
bu promise ve
future
sınıflarını
kullanıyor
arkadaşlar
şimdi
önce şuradan
başlayalım
promise ne demek
future ne demek
yani hiç
bu sınıflara
girmeden
sınıfların
üye fonksiyonlarına
falan bakmadan
biliyorsunuz
promise zaten
ingilizce'de
söz vermek
vaat etmek
demek
promise sınıfı
türünden
bir nesne
aslında
neyi
temsil ediyor
ileride
hesaplanacak
bir değerin
bir şekilde
iletilmesi
sözünü
veriyor
ama
promise'in
hazırladığı
değeri
elde etmek
için de
onu kullanmak
future
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesne
ihtiyacımız var
yani aslında
bir iletişim
kanalı söz
konusu
bir ucunda
promise nesnesi
var
bir ucunda
future nesnesi
var
aslında yapılan iş şu
son derece basit
bu
en son söyleyeceğimizi
en başta söylersek
arkadaşlar
bunu
ister doğrudan
kullanın
ister
async fonksiyonu
ya da
package task
sınıfını
kullanın
aslında yapılan iş şu
önce
promise sınıfı
türünden
ben şimdi
sembolik yazıyorum
çok sayıda örnek yapacağım
önce promise sınıfı
türünden
bir nesne
oluşturuyorsunuz
dikkat
tabi bu arada
ben böyle yazıyorum
promise de
future de
bunlar jenerik sınıf
bunların
template argümanı
aslında o
iletilecek
değerin türü
yani örneğin
hesaplanıp
başka bir türe de
iletilecek değerin
türü
int ise
promise'in
int
açılımını
double ise
promise'in
double açılımını
string ise
promise'in
string açılımını
kullanıyorsunuz
ama ben şimdi
sembolik olarak
böyle yazayım
arkadaşlar bir promise
nesnesinin
get future
isimli
bir üye fonksiyonu var
promise
nesnesinin
get future
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınız zaman
get future
fonksiyonu da
bu sefer
size
future sınıfı
türünden
bir nesne döndürüyor
ama
tıpkı
promise gibi
future sınıfı da
bir sınıf
şablonu
yani
jenerik bir sınıf
ve get future'ın
geri döndürdüğü
nesnenin
türü
bu sefer de
future'ın
o açılımı
yani örneğin
bizim promise'imiz
promise'in
int açılımı
türündense
onun
get future
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımızda
o da bizi
start future'ın
int açılımı
türünden
bir
nesne
veriyor
yani
tipik olarak
aslında biz ne yapıyoruz
önce bir promise
nesnesini hazırlıyoruz
sonra onun
get future
nesnesini
fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
ondan bir future
nesnesi elde ediyoruz
burada
dikkat
ne zamanki
promise nesnesi
yoluyla
veri
hazırlanacak
o veri
elde edilecek
o noktadan
sonra ben
future
nesnesinin
get
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
onun
elde ettiği
değeri
o get
fonksiyonunu
bana verecek
yani
promise diyor ki
ben ileride bir
değerin
hazırlanmasına
üretilmesi
sözünü
veriyorum
işte bu
sözüm karşılığı
o değeri elde
etmek istiyorsanız
benim
future'ımı
get future'la
elde edin
ve
o
get
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınızda
get future'ın
geri döndürdüğü
future nesnesinin
get fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınızda
işte
benim ürettiğim
değerin
kullanmış
olacaksınız
eğer değer
halen
üretilmemişse
get fonksiyonu
thread'ı
bloke edecek
ve o değer
hazırlanana
kadar bekleyecek
burada
entemsan noktalardan
biri
bu future
ve promise'in
tabi tipik olarak
asenkron
çalıştırılması
yani
bir thread'den
bir thread'e
veri ya da
exception'in
aktarılması için
kullanılıyor olması
fakat
senkron çalıştırmakta da
herhangi bir şekilde
bir engel
yok
arkadaşlar
şimdi
önce
kullanımını
basit olarak
bir gösterelim
sonra yavaş yavaş
detaylara
gireceğiz
arkadaşlar
gerek future
gerek promise
sınıflarının
anımı
future başlık
dosyasında
dolayısıyla
bunlardan
herhangi birini
kullanmak için
çoğu zaman
zaten ikisini
birlikte
kullanmak zorundayız
future başlık
dosyasını
dahil edeceğim
evet
şimdi tekrar
söylüyorum
başlangıçtaki
örnekler
senkron
olabilir
sadece
üye fonksiyonları
göstermek için
ama çoğunlukla
kullanımı
asenkron
olacak
necant bu arada
senkron
asenkron
sözlüklerini
ne anlamda
kullanıyorsun
yani
senkron olması
demek
tek threadle
çalışacak
biri bitecek
ondan sonra
diğeri başlar
asenkron olması
demek
arkadaşlar
biri çalışırken
diğerinin de
çalışıyor olabilmesi
demek
mesela bakın
stut promise
türünden
bir nesne
oluşturuyorum
promise'in
int açılımı
from
buraya dikkat
ve
bunun
get future
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
hemen
bir noktada
çağırabilirim
prom'un
get future'ı
şimdi bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri
aslında şu
stut future'ın
int açılımı
diyelim ki
bunun ismi de
ptr olsun
buraya dikkat
burada yine
aslında
şöyle de
yazabilirdim
arkadaşlar
bu durumda
yine
sitat devreye
girerdi
ya da
ototark deduction'la
otot
ftr'de
yazabilirdim
yani şunların
hepsi aynı anlamda
stut future'ın
int açılımı
türünden
ftr
biraz yavaş
gidelim
bu konuda
çok önemli
ya da
sitat
tamamen
ototark deduction
şimdi bakın
bütün hikaye
aslında şu
ben
prom'un nesnesinden
future'ı
elde ettiğimde
belirli bir noktada
future'ın
get fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
get'in
geri dönüş
değeri
işte
promise'in
vaat ettiği
söz verdiği
değer
yani örneğin
promise'in
int açılımı
söz konusu
olduğunda
get fonksiyonunun
çağrısı
future'ın
get fonksiyonunun
çağrısı
bana
geri dönüş
değeri olarak
int değer
verecek
eğer
future
örneğin future'ın
int yerine
double açılımı
olsaydı
onun get fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
double değer
elde edecektim
şimdi
get fonksiyonu
burada
veri hazırsa
zaten
thread
yoluna devam
edecek
veriyi
elde edeceğim
get fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri olarak
veri hazır
değilse
thread'i bloke
edecek
yani diyelim ki
şu anda
single thread
olarak çalıştıracağım
diyelim ki
thread halen
çalışıyor
işini bitirmedi
o veriyi
iletmek için
işlemler
devam ediyor
o zaman
get fonksiyonunu
thread'i bloke
edecek
ne zamanki
işler bitti
veri hazır
o zaman
thread bloke
olmaktan çıkacak
ve get fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş değerini
kullanabileceğiz
peki şimdi burada
soru
o iki tane
bir tane
kanal var
paylaşılan
bir state var
state'in bir ucunda
aslında
promise nesnesi
diğer ucunda da
future nesnesi var
bunlar
aynı kanalı
kullanarak
bir iletişim
sağlıyor
peki
veriyi
o kanala
nasıl veriyoruz
burası önemli
arkadaşlar
promise sınıfının
iki tane
önemli fonksiyonu var
başka fonksiyonları
da var da
şimdilik bizi ilgilendiren
iki tane
önemli fonksiyonu var
biri
set value fonksiyonu
işte
üretilecek
değeri
ileteceksem
set value
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
mesela bakın
set value
şimdi
değeri
ürettim
ve
kanala
yükledim
artık
future nesnesi
get fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
bana bu
değeri döndürecek
ama bir
exceptions
iletmek
istersem
bu seferde
set
exception
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
arkadaşlar
set exception
fonksiyonu
daha önce
exception
ending'de
gördüğümüz
exception
ptr
türünden
bir argüman
istiyor
set value
fonksiyonu da
iletilecek
değer neyse
yani
promise'in
int açılımıysa
int türden
değer
promise'in
string
açılımıysa
efendim
string
türünden
değer
bekliyor
şimdi ben
önce
single
trade
çalıştırayım
pekala
böyle
çalıştırmanın
da
mümkün
olduğunu
ama
pratikle
tabi bir
fayda
sağlamadığını
göreceğiz
izleyin
get future'u
çağırdım
ve şimdi
set value
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
set value
fonksiyonuna
değerini
set ettim
ve artık
ptl'nin
get
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
get fonksiyonu
bana bu değeri
verecek
see
alt
bakın
value
eşittir
şimdi diyeceksiniz ki
peki
necum bunu
asenkron nasıl
çalıştıracağım
son derece
basit
asenkron
çalıştırmak
için
bir şekilde
sizin
oluşturduğunuz
örneğin
promise nesnesini
bir başka
thread'in
çalıştıracağı
fonksiyona
argüman olarak
geçmeniz
gerekiyor
bunda nasıl
yapıldığını
birkaç örnekle
göstereceğim
arkadaşlar
yani
tipik olarak
a
şöyle bir
fonksiyon
oluşturacaksınız
yavaş yavaş
biraz da
zaman problemimiz
var
hepsini
yavaş yavaş
göstereceğim
ya şöyle bir
fonksiyon
oluşturacaksınız
bu
fonksiyonun
parametresini
ya
promise
türünden
ya arkadaşlar
promise
türünden
l value
referans
ya da
promise
türünden
r value
referans
yapacaksınız
bu arada
promise
sınıfı
movable
bir sınıf
arkadaşlar
evet
yani
non
capable
but
movable
şimdi
diyelim ki
full fonksiyonunun
parametresini
şöyle yazdınız
tut
promise'in
int açılımı
tabi ki
bu
fonksiyonun
başka argümanları
olamayacağı
anlamına
gelmiyor
diyelim ki
int x
ve bu fonksiyonun
yavaş yavaş
gidelim
bu fonksiyonun
bir thread
tarafından
çalıştırılması
söz konusu
olacak
ama
işte
bu
bunu çalıştıran
thread
buradaki
promise nesnesini
kullanarak
kanala
set edilen
değeri
yükleyecek
bu
promise'in
future'ını
alan
yani
promise'in
get future
fonksiyonunu
çağıran
thread'de
bu
promise nesnesi
işini
bitirdiğinde
yani
set value
ya da
set exception
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığında
diğer değeri
alabilecek
şimdi
basit bir örnek
olarak
şöyle gösterelim
arkadaşlar
bakın
see out
bu
çağırıldı
promise'in
set value
fonksiyonunu
çağırdık
tabi
set value
fonksiyonu
bizden
intür'den
bir değer
bekliyor
bu
başka bir
fonksiyonu
da çağırabilir
ama
set value
fonksiyonunu
çağırdık
örneğin
x
çarpı
değerini
set etti
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
takip edin
tamam
şimdi artık
bu set value
fonksiyonunun
fonksiyonuyla
set edilen
değeri
bu
promise'in
future'ı
bize get
fonksiyonuyla
verecek
future değeri
capable
mı
yani
iki farklı
thread
tek bir
promising
get future
değerini
kullanabilir
mi
çok güzel
bir soru
erken bir
soru
evet
ama
bunun için
shared future
isimle
ayrı bir
future sınıfını
kullanmamız
gerekiyor
yani
bir
future
sınıfı
var
tabi
şu anda
konunun
çok çok
başındayız
yavaş yavaş
ilerleyeceğiz
bir de
shared future
sınıfı
var
yani
hazırlanan
değerin
birden fazla
thread tarafından
kullanılması
gerekiyorsa
birden fazla
thread'in
aynı
üretilen
değeri
kullanmasını
istiyorsanız
o zaman
future değil de
shared future
sınıfını
kullanıyorsunuz
evet bakın
şimdi
buraya kadar
derleyelim
olabilecek
en basit örneği
ve
şöyle bir
yapımız
olsun
is
in
see out
main
is
running
şu anda
sadece
bir
thread var
tabi
bu arada
yanlış anlaşılma
olmasın
bunu
illa main
olması
gerekmiyor
başka bir
fonksiyon
da olabilirdi
ama
şimdi bakın
önce bir
promise
nesnesi
oluşturuyorum
stud
promise'in
beklediğim değerin
türü ne
int
açılımı
from
onun
future'ını
get future
kompsonu ile
elde ediyorum
from
get future
arkadaşlar
ve
bunu da bir
değişkende
tutuyorum
future'ın
bunu demin
konuşmuştuk
int
açılımı
ftr
tamam
şimdi bakın
bu fonksiyonu
ben herhangi bir
threadle
çalıştırabilirim
şimdi asenkron
çalıştırmaya
şimdi
başlıyoruz
ister bir
stud thread
nesnesi
kullanın
ister
c thread
nesnesi
kullanın
mesela
stud thread
h
arkadaşlar
thread'in
konstruktörüne
biz
bir
kollable
ve o
kollable'ın
parametrelerine
gönderilecek
argümanları
geçmiyor muyuz
işte
kollable olarak
foo'yu
ve bir de
foo'ya gönderilecek
argümanları
geçiyorum
şimdi burada
taşıma semantiğinden
faydalanma
şansım var
yani
stud
move
söyleyip
prom
ilettim
ve tabi
başka argüman
varsa
o argümanlar
mesela
diyelim ki
böylece
bu thread
koşmaya
başladı
şimdi
ne zaman ki
ben
ftr'nin
get fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
get fonksiyonu
bana
üretilen
değeri verdi
auto
ya da
int
i var
eşittir
ftr'nin
geti
siyah
join de
edelim
t'nin
join'i
yani
aslında
makro düzeyleri
isim bu
bundan sonrası
artık yavaş yavaş
detaylara gireceğiz
threadlerden biri
promis nesnesini
oluşturdu
o promis nesnesinin
future'ını
elde etti
evet
hesaplanacak
değeri hesaplayacak
thread'e
bir şekilde
promis nesnesini
iletti
tabi
o promis nesnesini
iletmesi
farklı şekillerde
olabilir
hepsini
göstereceğim
mesela promis nesnesinin
kendisi
global bir değişken
olabilir
efendim
taşıma
semantiğiyle
geçilebilir
ya da
l-value
referansa
reference
wrapper'la
sarmalanabilir
ya da
fonksiyonun
parametresi
zaten
promis türünden
bir
r-value
referansı
olabilir
doğrudan
r-value
olarak
geçip
promis nesnesini
r-value
referansa
bağlanmasını
sağlayabilirim
evet
see out
ne diyelim
ival
eşittir
sadece bir giriş
yapmış olduk
çarşamba
günkü dersimizde
future
ve promis
sınıflarını
ve bunların
kullanımını
ayrıntılı
olarak göreceğiz
hemen
aliham
bostor'ın
sorusuna cevap
verelim
daha konunun
çok başında olduğunuz
için aslında
sorduğunuz
soruların
hepsinin
cevabı
önümüzdeki
dakikalarda
olacaktı
ama
daha
arkadaşlar
oraya
gelmedik
aliham
promis nesnesini
bir daha
set edebiliyor
muyum
hayır
arkadaşlar
promis nesnesini
bir kere
set edebiliyorsunuz
ve ya
set value
fonksiyonunu
ya
set exception
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsunuz
ikinci kere
set etme
girişiminde
bulunduğunuz
zaman
exception
throw ediyor
bu bir
aynı şekilde
get fonksiyonunu
bir kere
çağırabiliyorsunuz
get fonksiyonunu
bir kere
çağırdığınız
zaman
yani
kanaldan
üretilmiş
değeri
aldığınız
zaman
future
nesnesi
invalid
hale
geliyor
ve artık
invalid
durumdaki
bir future
nesnesinin
get fonksiyonunu
tekrar çağırırsanız
yine
exception
throw ediyor
ama
eğer burada
kullanılan
az önce
arkadaşımın
sorduğu
birden fazla
threadle
kullanabilir miyim
eğer
burada
kullanılan
future
nesnesi
stud future
türünden
değil de
stud shared
future
türünden
olsaydı
o zaman
get fonksiyonunu
birden fazla
kez
kullanabilecektim
main scope
da oluşmuş
bir değişkenin
bir member
değerini alıp
sonra main scope
da oluşan
değeri
move yapınca
future
de allocated
olur mu
diye
endişelendim
ama olmadı
hayır hayır
arkadaşlar
bütün bu soruların
cevabı
dediğim gibi
sadece bir giriş
yaptık
bundan sonraki
derste göreceğiz
arka planda
neler oluyor
onu konuşacağız
ama şunu da
söyleyeyim
bakınız
neden future
ve promise
sınıflarını
başta
anlatıyorum
çünkü
izleyin
daha sonra
göreceğimiz
async fonksiyonu
daha yüksek
seviyede
dedik ya
daha önce
daha sonra
göreceğimiz
async fonksiyonu
bize doğrudan
zaten future
nesnesini verecek
yani
geriye kalan
her şeyi
halledecek
dolayısıyla
ben
diyelim ki
şöyle bir
fonksiyonu
dersin başında
seviyeden
bahsettik ya
şöyle bir
fonksiyonu
ben
paralel olarak
çalıştırıp
geri dönüş
değerini
almak istiyorsam
hiç
doğrudan
fonksiyonun
parametresini
efendim
promise
vesaire
yapmadan
ismi
async olan
fonksiyonu
çağıracağım
buraya dikkat
işte onu
asynke geldiğimizde
göreceğiz
async fonksiyonuna
arkadaşlar
çalıştırılacak
fonksiyonu
vereceğim
ve
gelin ki
bu
ve
doğrudan
async fonksiyonu
sembolik olarak
yazıyorum
bana
bir future
verecek
asynkin
geri dönüş
değerini
future
nesnesinde
tutacağım
ve
future'ın
get fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
o fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değerini
alacağım
evet
peki
arkadaşlar
hepsi için
bol bol örnek
vereceğim
dediğim gibi
daha sadece
konuya
yeni başladık
Emirhan Bey'in
sorusu var
neden bu
ikiliye
ihtiyaç
duyuyorum
çünkü
burada
aslında
bir
shared
variable
olması
gerekiyor
değil mi
eğer böyle
hazır bir yapı
olmasaydı
biz
bir tane
shared
variable
oluşturacaktık
onu
mutex'e
koruyacaktık
biri
mutex'e
koruma altında
shared
variable'a
değeri
yazacaktı
diğeri de
yine mutex'e
edinip
shared variable'ın
değerini
kullanacaktı
ama şimdi
bu bunu
adeta
otomatik
hale getiriyor
yani
romis nesnesini
kullanarak
biz aslında
arka planda
oluşturulan
bir
shared state
var
biz onu
doğrudan
görmüyoruz
set value
fonksiyonuyla
o shared state'e
değeri
yüklüyoruz
ama future'ın
da get
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyoruz
yani doğrudan
mutex'i
vesaireyi
kullanmadan
arka planda
bu
sınıfın
oluşturduğu
promis sınıfının
shared state
arka planda
kullanılıyor
biri o
shared state'e
bir değer
yüklüyor
diğeri de
alıyor
ama arka
planda
doğrudan
senkronizasyon
sağlanıyor
yani
bizim artık
senkronize
etmek için
ilave bir
kod yazmamıza
gerek
kalmıyor
yani
oradaki
set value
fonksiyonuyla
future'ın get fonksiyonu
doğrudan
kendi içinde
bir senkronizasyon
ilişkisi içinde
ama bütün bunları
işte
bir sonraki
derste göreceğiz
evet biraz fazla
uzattım
derse katıldığınız için
teşekkür ediyorum
çarşamba günkü
derste görüşmek üzere
herkese
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
eğer arkadaşlar
abone ol